[Music]
so
[Music]
my
so
to hear you hear you sunday
the lord's day y'all know what it is
what's going on how my levels sound i
see so many people in there already
that's what motivated the man the
legendary stand up what's going on
tell me i'm standing out here yosemite
blam
what's going on man yeah he's going to
talk some starfield we got maddie plays
in the building
paul saw what's going on for howard haye
what's going on
thank you what's going on able acid
what's going on
game play-doh pong soul what's going on
and uh let me get it right
pycon fusion pie confusion
feels good no man so we got a phone man
with the dave um we got the legend
in here you already know my man maddie
plays
should be a fun one we'll get into it um
no song today
it's always got some stuff going on with
the fam everything is good but you just
you know
something that the massive explanator
can start yeah the mass effect static
and stuff addicts say what's up to the
field
[Music]
yeah i gotta try it i gotta download it
oh no bad i got it down where i gotta
try to see what's going on
but um yeah man we'll get maddie plays
in here soon
i guess that's the love to solve taking
some time off with the family
he earned it
i'm gonna take a month off you're gonna
take him off strike
rebellion or a drink
anyway so look we will be back maddie
will be up in here shortly and of course
you know the king will pull up
all that good stuff you already know so
i told you guys in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i'll be eating these rappers
but that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game
just be original y'all so dramatical i
know it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
a proclamation
[Music]
if i can imagine it's cool to get you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that
option you're gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in a crucible was it in
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right and we are live hear you hear
you
and welcome to the iron lords podcast
and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 210 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got starfield 2022
rubens
early game announcements and bio mutant
performance to discuss
so we're going to get right into it i
want to introduce a lord whose content
not only represents a fusion of
informative game discussion
entertainment and consistency
but always finds a way to utilize his
original ideas with a pure passion for
the video games industry
introducing the creator of the vista
body plays youtube and twitch channels
and the host of the ham radio and
defining duke podcast
the lord of rpgs
fellow mets fan who always reminds us to
stay
sexy and stay active live from
my empire state new york
and making his debut into the realm of
the lords
mommy lord mr maddie please how we doing
sir
dude absolutely excellent that might
have been the biggest hype tape of my
life
you hit everything i've done in my
lifetime in like two minutes i was like
wow
he got it all i love that that was great
thank you i'm more excited to be here
now
appreciate it i was already happy
you just hit all my life achievements in
one second
all right much appreciated brother you
are a
lord and what you do it's only right we
show you the proper respect here act
around you
first of all how are you doing sir what
what have you been playing games wisely
let's go
wow so yeah it's been a it's been a busy
week of just playing a lot of stuff
because
um i've been reviewing bio mutant
that'll be out this coming week
um we've been doing a lot of mass effect
as
you said rpgs what version
uh for biomed uh i've been doing uh xbox
great
the now definitive version it's awesome
you need that good experience don't fall
into it
i gotta watch
been uh been playing jade empire that
has been uh a nice little uh
backtracking
it's tied into some content i'm doing
and uh let's see i think that
yeah those are the main three that i've
been i've been hitting up for about the
last week or so
um and just trying to balance all of
those has been been interesting to say
the least but it's been it's been good
gaming it's been good gaming i can
imagine man yeah you've been killing it
with the games i try to catch a little
bit of the uh the mass effect uh what is
it insanity
joyce oh yeah i love it i love it man
it's good to see man
that's what's up guys we gonna get into
this show you know what i'm saying but
you already know we got the four horse
well actually not the four horsemen man
shout out to salvation after lord solve
he is doing the family thing he has
earned the day off in the round
so send some love to somebody doing it
no days off
can't work a tight ship no day's off
this is the king of the days
you sit here with an iv in your arm oh
my god in the hospital with a
no doubt but you already know we got the
three loads of gaming in the realm
original lords here trying to respect uh
my man maddie plays time with some
time-sensitive intros
my co-host nicole my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world
and the how of the young wolf my man
who's demanding an updated intro
lord addict how are we doing sir still
demanding apparently
they're doing pretty good man uh you
know yesterday i finally finished the
mass effect trilogy
that that took me a week of like no
lifeing like
it was funny but like the longer the
the franchise went the worse it got like
oh no no no i'm talking about like
spending time on the game oh
i'm scared it was like the first one
like i didn't really care for a lot of
the side content in the first one
right so i just did like pretty much
like the bare minimum
yeah the main questions i was like what
what's what's getting me towards the end
all right there i'm going that way
like the second one i'm like oh man i
kind of want to do this
are you implying that mass effect 2 had
generated more interest for you
no no i'm here i'm applying that mass
effect 3 generate the most interest
there we go
but i but i didn't ask you that i would
be petty i would have the best effect
two genders no no if you did not
next no that's effect three is the gold
out of the tree thank you
thank you thank you continue i'll move
on oh you want to move on now
i see big wilhelm scream in the chat
well we playing a certain raid sir
yeah shout out to you frauds shout out
to you frauds
i get up yesterday and i see y'all in
the rink i said on god in them
i i hate these dudes i said oh god then
i see
i've seen some extra dudes in there i
just wanted to be really rude and jump
in your chat cause y'all was alive
i was just gonna be really rude but then
i said to myself you know what they're
streaming
and they will have documentation
i decided to sit my petty down and kill
them
first this is true
we we we went in the vault of glass and
we never left the ball to class
so you know wait for that for that
i got through that templar man and i i
really i don't remember him hitting so
hard
like contest maybe it's because the
contest rules but
like man i feel like like when when
people are killing you in the well
that's when you really you got to
re-choice
whatever you're doing in life because
it's just like i'm just saying like why
is he killing me i've been well
maddie you have no idea how good i felt
because i had fomo yesterday
and i felt really left out and i was
going to talk about it in my segment but
i'm glad you brought it up
we'll get you with that dad's been there
miss lord
yeah it's it's uh it's it's been a nice
little uh
nice little thing i i've enjoyed it now
you want to get on the
super chance to solve it's not in
because i know they're starting to fly
in a little bit
but um we're gonna get about after i get
a king up in here
yeah we'll get them back i know doubt
you already know and of course we have
the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
and is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how are we doing sir
we're doing fantastic and
check this out
[Music]
liking our little film
you wish that to happen i got you but um
i didn't wish it happened
so obviously i didn't have i'm gonna
shut off the camera i'm gonna turn it on
but don't that's actually
new kos is up whoa shout out to josh
taylor he's a uh
the undisputed walter with junior walter
weight champion in the world fantastic
fight last night it was great
uh also did uh sick mansions uh podcast
last night go check that out if you want
to see
you know new statue stuff uh we got the
statue stuff coming on tuesday with me
and cog unboxing an incredible statue
this is cogs first statue we're popping
this cherry
it's gonna be uh fantastic thing it's a
great thing it's a great show
plus y'all get a chance to see me unbox
thanos right there
oh my lord whoa you know xm studio
thanos i did that especially for
for cod to be honest with you because
this statue
that he's been waiting for is we
waited together for a year yeah you know
and he
he he paid the statue off i paid the
pass statue off he got his first
so he's been very patiently holding his
mind comes on monday
and we're gonna do a double unboxing
plus we have a special guest coming
through on dcx
uh with another statue to do it and
thanos because
that's between me and kyle yeah you know
this is just betty i've been avoiding
this thing
for so long i'm like i am not getting
caught up in that culture
it's way out my price range but yeah
it knows me and there's you know certain
characters
in my childhood that are really and when
it's done well
i'm like damn i gotta take the plunge on
this one
so i'm i'm i'm processing everything
right i'm adjusting here so you have so
many statues that you got a statue on
top of a box that has
you in there am i getting that right so
you can see mario is the policeman down
here
so all of them in line you know yeah
so anytime they get out of line weeks
ago he killed lean yeah
you killed elixir he killed zelda
well whatever i love it man thank you
thank you so much what i've been playing
this week
um i was playing destiny earlier you
know to get my light level up to get
ready for the raid that i wasn't a part
of oh god um
i mean you can you can jump in on after
the podcast oh no i
definitely am i i definitely am um i was
playing i went back to
outriders to up my um the level
of my techromancer because i've noticed
a lot of guys out there using the
techromancer wrong
and i've got my tech romance's turrets
down to three second um
respawns nice and my build my firepower
build is incredible so i'm doing
right now uh 400 million damage
a solo and i can solo by myself 10
15 um expeditions and that's the fix
using the joint that gives you the
health back yes yeah i like that
and very good both turret blight turrets
and which one
my build is crazy i gotta ask what's the
other you use the
the turret and what's the avatar i use
both turrets i use the oh
got you yup the freezer and
then i'm getting my health back and i
keep them on the field so i can have at
least five to six turrets going at one
time while i'm you know killing the boss
freezing
it's like a team by myself isn't it um
also uh um i was going inside the back
catalog i was playing psychonauts
because um i got a little information
because i have to finish this game up
because
it's about to drop uh and i've been
saving my money this month i had a hard
choice between
uh biomutant and um resident evil eight
okay i finished resident evil seven uh
like i told you guys
i buckled down i played the game
horrifying beautiful game please don't
say this story ends with you
buying biome no no i
you know and i and i am because i waited
for bio mutant for so
long okay and everybody that i've seen
that even had any
inkling of touching the game that's why
i'm very interested in maddie's uh
maddie plays
review on the game to be honest with you
very seriously
because everybody says it's what they
expected and what they wanted and
visually from this small studio
it's amazing even though it's splash gen
it's visually amazing so
that's where my money is going um and by
the time i do get around to the resident
evil because i got two to play
the remake and three remake to play
it'll be
probably in game pass or be cheap so no
doubt you already
know um attic you want to get these
super chats in now or cause i see a
couple of from
all the way from the place go ahead and
get them yes we gotta find our super
trap from flame morning realm who is
ready for the bio mutant especially
after th cool body and that troll who
tried to mock the dev team
disgusting you got anything to say about
that king i know i got a lot to say
you've got a lot to say at the time
later
when that topic pops up and follow the
super jack from pucci
what's i can't it's that name i love it
what's good
family got lord maddie on here lord
bethesda himself whoa
all right how we feeling about hellblade
2 news and it's not being an e3 per
jeff grove how you feeling about that
yeah that's a
i i don't know what's going on with that
game because
i feel like when they revealed it at the
game awards you're like all right it's
pretty safe expectation we'll see it's
like a year or two right we'll get a
good idea but jeff's saying it's not an
e3 it's a little surprising
um you know you think you get some kind
of update because xbox and their
their notion of reveals makes no sense
to me right we'll obviously get into it
but it seems like they're pulling the
trigger early on star fields
and and kind of like revealing that they
revealed fable which was like leaked for
for years they
revealed that suddenly and that was like
two years out um they just have this
tendency to do that
there's no way we're getting perfect
dark relatively soon
because that was like a startup studio
that they're they're building over time
so it's like man yeah i i don't
i they're so hard to predict i thought
that would be a sure shot thing you know
yeah we'll see a little hell blade too
but
i guess not i trust jeff so you know a
little surprising yeah we'll see what
happens we got somebody smith right
hannah
yeah so we gotta find out from smitty
smith shout out to iop kos the attic
show
logged in ariel knights never yield the
book of x
oh salute we hit him with the book of
acts right quick we gotta find out
from dustin furman much love to maddie
and all right
lord dustin all from our the legendary
that's what's up a hand pocket we're
gonna get into it man our salute to the
legend
all right we gotta find out superchat
from the talk you fix i definitely
butchered you janae we're gonna move
right past that though
uh uh madden here i thought that xbox s
was the
1080p machine with the ps5 proved me
wrong have a great show
hold up i have to refresh it i got it
let me get hustle hustle to motivate
that's the man dv stand up
go play aerial nice devil yield is fun
and the music is super dope yes
love the podcast you are all great shout
out to mr maddie plays
hey thank you salute hustle and motivate
and of course my
bro fonzarelli gaming
love my brothers here thank you for
always being here on a sunday
except for south oh damn kitty seriously
thank you for all you bring to the video
much love fonzero
yeah shout out to him one of the
believers in iop from the very beginning
and yo go salute him man he's got a new
podcast going on 101 series he
interviews devs
games talk hit that up man he goes right
after iop so if you got a long day you
want to podcasts man go rock
out with farms next month it's gonna be
a long week for me i'm gonna have to do
something to be up
yeah no doubt you got you caught up at
it because i
hope otherwise no we're not i have to
keep refreshing don't worry i got you we
got a two dollar strip trap from 108
shout out to dragons then podcast 108
dragons tv saturdays you already know
what it is new york stand up brooklyn
uh-oh and and we gotta fight our
scripture from forte
happy sunday lords have a great show hey
king booboo you gotta do it to someone
hey
i ain't doing something hey hey he's
doing hey
i gotta do hey first of all that's
uh raid talk so yeah that's why you talk
salute he's got a five dollar trip
gerald mack all held the iop shout out
to the lords
great show let's get it sir jeremy all
right
and the last one let's get the last one
in before we take a little break forward
there's there's another one
over there luigi i got it we got to
fight out okay yes
you got to fight out the super chat from
paco luigi hey lords love your content
here to rep my man mr maddie played
heavily involved in my community man i
love this guy that's great man thank you
falco much
love and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that realism
around the iop not telling what you want
to hear but what you need
to hear so shout out to the last word
one boy ibontis man we had the legend in
the building man we had uh mark takat
from guardian radio huge destiny og one
of the very first destiny podcasts ever
and now he's actually branching off he's
been doing this thing called the
enthusiast
life which is like geek culture and you
know all things
everything gaming and outside of destiny
as well as geek culture so so look him
was good he hasn't played destiny a
while he came back he's given his
thoughts and stuff telling us old bungie
stories
before the game was released and yeah oh
man it was good so if you want to hear
like some real historic
talk check that out obviously we talk
some vaulted glass stuff and that
and uh yeah for me it's been finally
finished yakuza like a dragon
that game is absolutely hilarious yeah
since
it's okay i finished mass effect i'm
going to go back to that oh brother
i dropped like a part of me like rushed
to mass effect so much because i
like i have this problem if i if there's
a certain amount of time goes by
i feel like i got to play the game over
again i'm like i'm not doing that i'm
not doing that so i'm gonna go live
mass effect and go right back in the
like a dragon chair like nothing ever
happened i never left it
so good i'm new to the series and people
told me i could
play it because it's kind of like a
standalone with it with a new uh you
know protagonist and stuff and um
he it's so good because what it has is
good fusion
of being funny not taking itself
seriously but then having these really
deep
emotional tones like damn i kind of i
kind of felt that like
you don't say that kind of hit me away
so salute to the mass and they're good
to see that success or rgg studios i'm
not even gonna pronounce the full name i
always butcher it right you whatever
but shout out to them good to see that
and i'm turn-based i'm team turn-based
so i love to see it in that genre
and judgment will continue for other
guys who like the other thing more power
to you but that's that
um obviously we did a vaulted glass
stream shout out to everybody who came
in the raid to watch us
fail and laugh at us but it was oh
shout out to red outdoor for being petty
being messy
in our channel yeah put the frog alert
on my bed real quick that's my guy
but red outdoor in here clown us oh
i remember before the glass i did that
years ago it's so easy look at the
look at the lord struggling yikes
yeah oh he yikes you know what's funny
like
there's a part where now you they they
count out the oracles it used to be you
just killed them when they popped up
yeah the chat was like i've remembered
why didn't you guys remember so i'm just
sitting here like
it's been years i probably forgot yeah
and then i find out this morning that
that's a new mechanic in the game
that wasn't in the other one saran tell
me tell me how that happened how do you
remember
him get him we got to go because he he
didn't know that they changed mechanics
to the right he's thinking it's one for
one i'm like yeah
we got you but yeah yeah i heard they
lied to people and was not one for one
you know they got things in there they
got no business being in there at
certain parts that's difficult but yeah
shout out to that
we did that and now finally i could
devote 100 of my energy back into mass
effect legendary edition got to catch up
to manny plays
let's go moving it you know what i'm
saying but look
we got all that stuff taken care of but
uh no we got to get into what
you know that we got and what the laws
have been playing we got it to get into
what lord maddy plays has been up to man
his video game system history
his journey as a content creator and of
course what led him to creating the
amazing youtube channel and the
ham radio podcast as well as defining
duke podcast
so lord maddie let's start from the very
beginning man what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you in the game
all right uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
i i think my first one was game boy
color uh not in the traditional way like
everyone talks about oh you know he's
gifted to me
or whatever you know he's very young i
found mine in the backyard right
so about that i'm out there roman and
there it is purple
purple game boy color i'm just like yo
what is this thing man
wait it was in new york you had a look
did you find a little light was it a
little light on it
no no no no no okay
yeah it was out there in the backyard so
i pick it up i don't know what this
thing is right so i end up just taking
in messing around with it i
i slept with it in my bed i know man i
was just
and uh you know my parents eventually
the next morning they're like we're
gonna take that back i'm like
what do you mean wow find out it's
neighbors right this makes it it's like
they just don't fall from the sky so
my parents being the phenomenal people
they are like we'll get you your own so
they eventually got me my own
and that was really the start of it
right was the game boy color pokemon
blue
and and from there like really that
that's that's that that was it man
yeah there we go yeah you see that's
nice sitting there trying your hardest
to beat gary at the end where i think
his name was
red or blue now but here's
the thing is that pokemon like
everyone's got this charizard hype i'm a
big blastoise guy so like
i've always been i'm a venusaur person
all right i respect it
i respect it you know but that's not me
oh wow
y'all talking to double leg he
definitely is but i know what he's
talking about though but yeah
hey but if i battled your last choice i
i i stomp him with my voice
that's fair we got it
called flag i heard jess gordon at work
like blastoise is literally weak to
venus
yeah just from there it was game boy
advance n64
original xbox was kind of like the the
real story about munch's odyssey
you know diving into that it was like
one of the launch games okay okay wait
wait time my time out
you just jumped i just jumped away well
yeah
exactly wait a second go back right so
nintendo got you in you found it you
thought it was pennies from heaven and
yeah
he was in the bed and your mother was
like what's that he was like excuse you
and they found that that you thought you
find his keepers you had to find this
keeper's face
and yeah it's like no we're gonna get
you your own all right so now that you
had your own and then you
you know played these wonderful games
you went over to the nintendo 64.
we're not going to skip over the
nintendo 64 because that's
kind of a big moment that's right right
yeah yeah i didn't know what the uh the
time it was like i don't know
i can accelerate to the highlight all
right yeah so n64 was
was more of the i called the awakening
right you know because
you're playing all these sprite games
pretty much and and then i played
pokemon stadium
that was my joint yeah right every i
still play that game man like
everything's in 3d
you have a commentator i was so
surprised they never tried to continue
that type of friend right everyone's
like give me pokemon snap i'm like bro
put a photo mode next mainline game call
it a day
like call it a day and give us a new
stadium that don't go and give me
stadium stop it
i hyped that up and and so yeah i don't
know why they haven't gone back to that
but for me stadium was that moment where
you know you just
everything comes to life yeah and then
there's that interactivity
i remember n64 had some type of adapter
that you could like
control where you but you can talk about
the um the the
memory card adapter that you put at the
top
well i actually think yeah but there was
an expansion pack maybe it was called
where you could put the uh
yes you could put the like game boy
cartridges in or something oh okay you
talk about that one yes
yeah and and on stadium i had this
mind-blowing experience where i was
playing it was pokemon yellow this time
i was playing that on the big screen i
was like
dude this is wild man
so you know just what nintendo did it's
expensive now like
yeah i know oh expansion packs yeah
yeah what's funny is like in pokemon i
used to they used to be like a little
place you could put it in the pokemon
stadium like your
your pokemon from the games so i would
put all of my pokemon on that on that
little expansion
and then restart pokemon blue and bring
them all right back
it's nice because normally time i'm
outnumbered man
this is why i asked him about this
because this is around the time addy got
into this
and i mean the nintendo 64 did so many
different things people don't really
understand nintendo was very innovative
with that console itself with rumble
packs with analogs
with uh memory expansions all this
incredible stuff that they were trying
and doing with everybody
and they had iconic games that they
never brought forward like uh
uh pokemon uh coliseum stuff like that
and i just i just wanted to hear more
about it because i noticed like you said
this was your awakening in video games
like you had
you know the penny from heaven situation
but now this is actually your joint and
it's and it's going on
and this is probably what really defines
matty play going on so
i just really wanted to know more about
this yeah continue that stadium
yeah okay no it's it's all good i um i i
guess
what it really trails into is that like
i was on second dreamcast at one point
shenmue was my jam
all right got everyone in now i got some
respect all over it's because
because like shenmue is that to me i
always stuck out to me was
i was watching my brother play and
eventually i got my turn but
i got a story on how i destroyed his
dreamcast by the way but oh you gotta
i'm sitting there and i'm watching them
play and you can like check your watch
right because enchantment one for those
who don't know you would like
have times that you had to be in certain
places it was like this real living
breathing world and my brother's like i
gotta go there at eight and i'm like
what do you mean and watching him like
wait at a spot and eight hits and the
mission starts like
what that was wild man blew your mind
yeah yeah absolutely shenmue was
transformative for its time 100
real life simulator gotta go to sleep
with everything we could do yeah it
doesn't get
enough uh love nowadays i think for for
all just that level of interactivity
like you can just get drinks from the
vending machine you can
arcade but what i'm what i'm hearing is
yakuza
actually uh continues that type of uh
game pretty much
yeah it's like the spiritual success i
would agree yeah but good team yeah
what's crazy is like you guys have like
the show because i didn't really play
shimmer like
i play like the way the samurai that's
like a different one but it was
it it was it was more like you know
killing people
i remember that like at the beginning
you find someone on some
uh some train tracks and like you're
sitting there talking to them you're
you're tied up and if you don't convince
your way out of it
that the train just hits you you got to
start over again
i'm sorry continue on casting the [ __ ]
talking
to your hair yeah so uh the way i
destroyed the dreamcast was i had this
innovative idea right my brother tells
me he's like the dreamcast can play
music like if you put a cd in there yes
gets the newest ludicrous album
it's sitting there i'm just like yeah
i'm so i'm like all right
cool so he's got i don't know what game
it was man but
i once it was an nba or something like
that and i'm like i want to play nba
while listening to ludacris
right right salute and so i i throw both
discs in man
at the same time
and i just jack the system up man
um i had to beat five oh okay
no no no that made sense because had you
said you was 13 you would
get beat up yeah yeah absolutely no
no no no so yeah he freaked out about
that dude i wreaked havoc for my brother
when i was younger man i really did
i
yeah yeah put them in there and all you
hear was like i'm like that was
not big yeah like was it was it pure
terror in your
your face when you heard the sound like
scientific stair i'm not sure what's
happening right now but i
think it's not like
he thought it was happening yeah i was
looking at the screen waiting for
something to happen right i was waiting
for ludacris
well i've never done this maybe that's
what you're supposed to do right i
didn't know any better
[Music]
i think christmas uh later on i got the
original xbox
and uh that was that was a big deal
because i think nfl fever was huge i
love that game i
like i don't know no dude the the
football like not in football but like
just sports spin-offs back in that era
do not get enough love man we got some
really cool games and everyone
was one of my favorite people back then
yeah like and now they just
they're hitting your wallet that's what
yeah that's it
um dead set radio future was huge for me
and uh munch's odyssey like i said much
aside probably the most significant one
because
i think that was like the start of my
love for rpgs and it's kind of weird
because it's not really a role-playing
game it's it's more like
you make choices and they influence your
your ending but not like
a control the world sort of way yes uh
so for those who haven't played much as
odyssey
pretty much you have uh these mudakins
that are serving as like slaves or
um and they're being attacked by these
sligs and um
you pretty much got to free them and
fuzzles every level and
you can choose not to free them or
whatever and so as a kid
like being able to free them all and
then get like a good ending and then go
back and not free them all and get a bad
ending and just
seeing how dialogue changes with um i
forget his name but the guy who'll like
pop up and give you your mission
briefing pretty much
if you're like good karma or bad karma
he's he's going to talk to you
differently
and so what i always said to my parents
was like uh i wish i had to create your
uh what did i say choose your own
adventure game is what i call them
[Music]
i'm so glad you mentioned that not to
cut you but now you're good it was a
huge part of manchala because if
anyone's not familiar maddie right
it was one of those things where you get
these books and it wasn't a story that
you read from start
to finish it was one of those decisions
you get to certain parts of the book and
it's like
if you turn the page
and then the whole dynamic so it was
literally like a role play game
and it was a good trick to get kids to
read
sherlock holmes and it said like
because i had to drink something and it
was like if if you drink it or choose
not to turn to page like 20 something
so i decided to drink it and i got to
pay 20 something i said you've been
poisoned
yeah did you flip back right away you're
like no
i don't want to be poisoned and one
other shout out i want to give uh
is a book called grail quest uh any
unknown was here and a lot of people
remember this
it was literally like you had to have a
pen in the paper you had to get your
points
it was literally you know that sounds
awesome bro it's awesome it's a series
of them
grail quests look them up they are
amazing you have your hit points but
there's only one little trick that
a while if you play them enough you
start to get swat too is whatever it
says if you do this go here
but if it says hey go to page 13. you
knew you was dead
maddie i got a question okay did you get
a chance to play the playstation fives
uh
munch's uh game that oh oh uh soul star
yes yeah is is it is it a remix because
i didn't get a chance to play it
um is it a remake of it i'm here like
it's a real yeah it's a remake of it
imagining yeah yeah and reimagining a
lot of ways because they tell the story
completely differently
right it's more it's more dark honestly
and um
i should preface by the way for anyone
else i am like in a very very very very
small role in the game like
very very tiny role so like i should
just let everyone know that so in case
they're worried about any bias but yeah
it's like a it's like a remake slash
reimagining of abe's exodus and
it got a lot of flack um and i'm a
little biased in general just
like i just said i grew up this you know
i've played everyone i love them all
but i i really liked how they approached
the storytelling i thought it was it was
it was gripping because it was much more
dark and
it's something they've never they've
tapped into the darkness a lot in in the
opera games but not as much as
as this one right um and when you
combine that with some of it's like
it's tools that you can use like we see
so many crafting systems in games
nowadays like it actually works in this
one though
it makes sense because abe is
notoriously weak like you can't fight
with him so you got to use your
surroundings
so it makes sense for abe but i get why
i wouldn't job with people but yeah if
you have a chance to try it out at some
point i would say it's
yeah i'm thinking about it worth the
look you've got to rush to it i don't
think it's
it's that incredible i like a lot of the
other world games more
but i do i do think it's worth a play
like i think it's i do think it's good
so look at your beard can we can we do a
spoiler on the roll that you wrote
should they wait and get it and then you
know it's literally just like i'm
one slig that you'll hear over an
intercom
on the train level yeah so you just hear
me kind of talking like this and it's
just like yeah salute the battery man we
got here
we're gonna let you gloss over that yeah
thank you but continue your gaming
history so you talking dreamcast
and then right continuing to go on uh
yeah
interrupt me whenever man probably keeps
the flow of the show a little bit better
we're not just sitting here talking for
an hour
um yeah so the xbox was big and so yeah
i was talking about choosing my own
adventure games and i was and and i
remember walking into circuit city man
oh oh yeah and and we walk in and it's
me and my dad
and i see this 10 below bin
and that's like my dad being as amazing
as he is he's just like
he's like yeah right that's my game
[Laughter]
i really wasn't
[Laughter]
you felt like you were just picking them
all out you were just like yeah do
whatever i want now yes
yeah because you knew the price of games
so you knew if they said they was buying
you a game
and they had 50 bucks and then you said
okay
below ben i'm going into the below yeah
oh dude
you take a couple risks in there you're
like right now like this but it's five
bucks not my money like hey
let's go so uh yeah so
i i remember seeing splinter cell but um
the game that stuck out to me most i saw
star wars and i see the old republic
yeah
oh look at that like because i've only
at this point i was not a huge star wars
fan at all like i didn't even
care about it i didn't really i don't
even say i liked it you know i just
yeah um was disinterested in it if
anything and i see it though
and it's 10 bucks and i just remember
thinking this
doesn't look like star wars did you you
look at the front cover you'd see the
lightsabers and whatnot but you wouldn't
see the
clone troopers and and the droids that
were common during that era and i'm
thinking well
you know so i picked that out i'm like i
want this it was the platinum hits once
it was like the silver case and
everything
i go home my mind is blown first thing i
see
is creating your own character i go this
is what i imagine right because
we didn't have like we didn't have like
the internet was not as
relevant for for game coverage i feel
then um you get guides and whatnot but i
was not on there searching for games so
i would honestly over a lot of my games
i would tell my parents or my friends
like oh i wish i had this type of game
and they would show me flyers and stuff
from best buy
or circuit city or whatever and i'd
circle stuff that i think would would
be in that realm like i remember ninja
turtles game was one i wanted to see
my mom got me a uh official xbox
magazine
and that was one of the previews for it
and so i remember like reading about
that and saying like yeah i want this
and they got it for me for christmas
that was
sort of how the loop was man um they
they fueled the passion i always say i'm
eternally thankful for my parents man
they were they were incredible
and um so yeah they don't want you going
around claiming people boxes anymore
they got tired of games
that was probably a very awkward
conversation i think your kid took my
kids game boy
all right if you look at that moment of
like you know did we save some money and
go
no he didn't what are you talking about
if he really loved it he would have
slept with it i'm done
yeah right she's mine now
she chose me
uh yeah so kotor i i've talked to it to
the point of
if anyone is listening from my channel
oh my god man i talked about this game
of girls
now but i i i love this game like if i
can marry a video game this is it you
know
like i always i always tell cognito
because it's like
yo mass effect's good it is like it is i
feel like
if couture was built and designed around
the foundation of
through every game that mass effect was
couture would be that gay but
i love the first one i love the second
one you know probably the first one more
than because of the whole like mind
blown raven thing but like
like but besides that it's just like
there hasn't been
a time where i've played a game and i'm
like
these people man
i gotta give it to bioware like back
when back in those days man by where
they had you make decisions that you
would just like i don't know
why i don't know what to do like i'd
rather not play at this point
tough decisions but yeah talking about
that kotor and like
like you play it in like it just
instantly like
grabs you like what i think that was rpg
awakening yeah
yeah exactly that exactly that rpg
awakening for sure you know you just
like i said the character creator yeah
it wasn't extensive no you just like
pick a different portrait and whatnot so
you know like i was just running around
with whoever and but it was that moment
of like
choosing your stats yes and being like
well i could be
stronger and so i do like this full
strength that's the thing that as a kid
is like
more power yeah but it was like
customizing my experience to some extent
and then you get into
trascogo on the end our spire you're
talking to him and you just start to see
like three things you can choose to say
i'm like why i can
i can i can be myself and
because was you evil or was you oh i was
great i was good i was good okay okay
i was a good kid despite despite
destroying cds and systems
i was a good kid
the biggest question is is what
decisions did you make at the end
that that's when you was good or bad the
whole game isn't relevant what you did
at the end is what it matters yeah i
mean i'll say this much right like i
didn't understand the nuance of choice
quite well it's my first time going in
so like someone like johanni
she was dead she's dead man like i i was
like i'm not saving her you don't really
go through the whole game you're missing
a portrait in the party man you're like
oh i wonder what i'm gonna unlock this
girl and you don't because like you guys
said that you're supposed to have yeah
yeah i killed her too i killed her yeah
and i didn't even like what's funny is
that even though she's supposed to be
part of your party until years later
oh dude i think a lot of people had that
yeah they go back and they could play it
now shout out to xbox
it's amazing right oh yeah
yeah and um so yeah i played as a good
guy for that
and i think that that was really it
right like that was the game i went back
to and i kept playing i kept playing
like year after year after year man like
it was i would be in other games
but i was very much and i think a lot of
people talked about this with their
childhoods i was very much like a buy
and stick with it kind of guy very very
rarely i didn't come home with a haul
i'd come up with one game that'd be my
game for a while so
for people who are familiar with my
stuff they'll know like i'll talk about
certain games like pretty
authoritatively like kotor is one of
them because i have
decades of time spent in that game world
like i
i know like the back of my hand i think
my mine was final fantasy it's like
a lot of the final fantasy that's the
the reason why i had asked about the
nintendo because i thought she was going
to say that
like you i got hooked on zelda because i
know you and rpgs right
yeah but now when you had got to kotor i
saw your eyes light up
that's why you look to the left like you
get all these memories rushing in
this is like this is it this is the
going back because we talked about
fallout 76 earlier
before the movie started right so it's
stuff like this
that defines the person going forward in
our choices and what we pick
because mine was it started with turbo
graphics with
wise and some people call it easy yeah
yeah yeah you know
some of the best music right it was the
first cd that i put in
and it talked yes
the the the video the visuals and and
the game
and it started getting me into the rpg
down and i went to from final fantasies
and stuff like that
and fantasy stars and stuff like that
and final fantasy later
but i've i've noticed that were you
hooked to western rpgs going forward
or did you dabble in any japanese rpgs
yeah it's funny i was excited a lot of
people call me a weeb now
but you know girl growing up i was like
very anti-jrpg and the game that
broke that seal is pretty crazy it was
on the 360 no less it was it was final
fantasy
13-2 which is not like okay now he can
leave
what was it about it because again i'm
not what was it about it
i'm not judging
but i'm curious that as to why that
particular what
why did that break through to matt yeah
all right
so i really think it was just it was it
was self-awareness at this point is what
happened
because i played a ton of kingdom hearts
you know
but i was like you're back in you're
back in it yeah
yeah so you know i'm in that space i'm
playing these games uh
that uh that are are japanese developed
they are jrpgs but because they were
like more tailored to my tastes i'm like
they're not it's like the people who go
i i especially during my like growing up
i liked anime
yeah like naruto and stuff but people
are like oh that's that's weird you know
that's stupid
nowadays it's really popular but it's
crazy how that's happened
i know it could be weird but now it's
popular anime used to be weird now they
literally owns tick tock like
yeah the reason why is because we grew
up and we control everything but guys
uh yeah so i just realized one day that
these games i have been playing
some of them were jrpgs and so i was one
of those people who's like oh i don't
like that stuff and someone would go you
like dragon ball do you like pokemon to
be like yeah oh you like you like anime
right that was kind of that
moment and so like oh do you do you like
kingdom hearts yeah that's a jrpg
and well i guess i always have so it
became that
self-awareness where you go wow i i
guess i i
i do like these games and for me final
fantasy 13
2 was uh you you were talking about
vocals king
for me it was it was the first game i
can recall where
it wasn't just like instrumentals in the
background other games have done this
before but you heard
you just heard people singing singing
yeah and
and i remember that just really
resonating with big time i think it was
why i
it started off you know one of those
building blocks for why i'm such a freak
about persona because that's all that
game is man
yes they're just making true music and
they're like hey this they should fit
and they just throw it in there you know
it's funny i love making fun of persona
with the the
exaggerations when they say persona
right at the beginning of all their
turns
oh you didn't like anything they're like
and i'm like we stopped that please
don't yo you go get kybatsu man he hated
you we slandered his
persona
[Laughter]
yeah so that that's sort of like how i
fell into jrpgs and
um from there it was just you know
i guess it was just embracing who i was
because i i i get
i think that was sort of my thing
growing up like i was surrounded by like
i was
how do i say this i played sports but
like i was surrounded by kids who were
very clearly athletes
right and i i would say i had athletic
abilities but i was not an
athlete you know and so um for me gaming
was my thing and
you know i get teased about it from time
to time nothing like so severe like
bullying or anything but like
i mean it's happened occasionally but it
wasn't like that bad um
and until um i guess youtube's just
started to take off where i
i i thought i was alone on this right
like that was my mindset like i
literally was
sitting there playing these games i'd
sit in an xbox party with like
a buddy or two sometimes i just play by
myself most times i play by myself
because no one around me really was
interested and so youtube was
became over time really start with the
angry video game where did i do these
fake angry reviews i like yelling at a
camera and
thank god those videos are gone thank
god they're gone but
they were they were bad man and so and
you know so you you go a little bit
forward into it and i start making like
glitch videos tips and tricks videos and
i'm sure we'll get into that in a little
bit but it's good point being is is
you know for me it was like kind of that
it was multiple awakenings
and for me youtube served as this
comforting realization like hey you're
not the only guy sitting there because
it was
big in video games yeah yes it wasn't
enough where i would stop or i felt
weird but i felt like
at times you're like am i wasting my
time but i was like these are so good
there's
such great experiences here and um so
it's really thanks to youtube that i i
fell in love with it again and again and
again that's awesome
and then you actually saw like the views
and the likes or
or people subscribing and people looking
at whatever you were doing
and then that gave you affirmation to
all right you know a confirmation
in in that situation that okay what i'm
doing is right because
i remember when you said that the
internet wasn't so expensive for you
younger
and you were looking for like strategies
or how to
and and you know they would circle your
circle inside the magazine or circular
and they would think that this game is
for you but now that you had the
internet news using youtube and then you
was also
voicing yourself you were given a guide
to a void that you had that was missing
and that was in your space because you
said you know well maybe if they don't
know about this i can help that kid out
they didn't know because
you didn't hear you say anything like uh
you're like you had a tag team buddy
like i would always like have a tag team
buddy
at some point in time with games and
like you said you was a solitary person
when it came to these games and i know
rpgs resonate with you and i think
that's the reason why
yeah just like trying to analyze it
while we talking by all means yeah it's
really just having control of the
experience and like you know
because you're doing it on your own
right so rpgs are like the primary to me
at least they're the primary like insert
yourself into the world and just kind of
get immersed and i think that's why they
really sat with me because i
i had buddies that would like want to
play couch co-op
turtles in time you know on snes like
we'd get together at the school
we'd play mega man together that was a
pretty big deal boulder's gate dark
alliance was another one like these
couch co-op beat em ups with luke i
remember dark alliance
dark alliance is great man yeah what's
funny is i never finished that game
because uh
which one was on the gamecube uh they
had darker lines one and two so
i had that i had that and it got stolen
so it wasn't me
excuse me i was not in my backyard
okay because he says something i don't
want to
gloss over and king kind of expounded on
it too was that
you know one thing i appreciate you you
just said in reference to
you know having this passion for games
right but almost feeling like you're the
only one
right at the time and not having that
community and then
you know because you you actually
started youtube pretty early like about
13. if i'm mistaken like you started
early
i started really early yeah and and the
thing i it really resonates with me is
that
when i look because i'm older and i look
at the gaming community and to me it's
crazy that dudes are legit
beefing with each other over video games
right
i come from the air right we're from new
york where in my opinion like
the dudes that were in the game we were
clowns like it wasn't
cool to be a gay but it wasn't a lot of
us so when you found someone it was like
he was your brother all the best
yeah oh you probably love that game and
then either you trade it you exchange
and you just it was just brotherhood
because it was like this secret club
that not too many people you knew was a
part of it
and i'm so glad you said what you said
because at the end of the day that's why
i always try to
express to what i see people be like
real beef with each other because they
like a different problem like bro
at the end of the day game that guy it
should be your brother or that girl
should be your sister because
they love gaming you know what i'm
saying you get what i'm wrong with
yourself betty
absolutely yeah yeah because yeah i had
i had two buddies i can think of um that
that
we would exchange games and all and all
that stuff but
um you know outside of that it was like
it was it was pretty rare and so yeah
you embrace that friendship through
games like of course we we love one
another
just for each other but it was just yeah
it was one of those things where you
know
there are so many games that i would not
have discovered if it were not for them
like
i am you know because i'm pretty well
known for i'd say rpgs on my channel but
i don't think anyone knows how
obsessed i am with mega man like i play
that all the time like i've played
i'm not a big fan of like the classic
mega man but like i'm a huge fan of the
x series
you know like the x-command mission like
which is an rp turn-based rpg for mega
man are you kidding me there's
zero games yeah it's it's so good man
that's my attention
i'm like who's a yeah it's a great
it's a great space turn back okay it's
amazing man i love that
supposedly supposedly they're getting
remade or something like that i don't
know though
i would love if they did i i know that
there was that uh capcom leak that was
saying that they're doing something with
mega man apparently next year according
to their
internal documents so i was just like
crossing my fingers because the other
other mega man series i really like i
have the original copies of them is
battle network it was game boy advance
exclusive
yeah i actually got uh their sequel's
star force right here and so
oh this was nice dude i just i love mega
man so it's like you know if it weren't
for my buddy though who i lived near who
who would
get these games and then say hey come
over and check out mega man x8 it was
or check out command mission i'd be like
oh my god like i gotta
i gotta go oh i gotta see this thing and
when i did my you know mine was blown
again
interesting yeah see i'm not gonna shame
you with my little mega man love
i came from the nintendo nes cartridge
and where we had to leave it on because
it was no save feature
so don't touch turn the tv off your
mother doesn't know but the light is on
on your joint
yeah and she comes in and she's like oh
this is on
[Laughter]
real stuff and i love what you talk
about i want to um
transition real quickly because i know
we could talk you've got so much
like it's crazy um
you started to talk about the influence
of you know getting into
content creation right and you had some
of those videos some of that like little
angry reviews and stuff like that
so like you know what then started to
push you forward to say okay you know
what
i really want to do this regularly like
i really want to get into you know
youtube
it was two things uh first was
and this is going to sound sort of as
annoying but i'll
extrapolate a little bit more i
i didn't want to work a normal job i
don't know how else to say it right
i would really just hear people around
me constantly complaining about
retail or wherever they worked like it
was not great
and i always said as a i remember in
second grade i was sitting at my buddy's
house
talking to his mom and we were always
like you know what do you want to be
when you're older
and i always said lawyer because my
parents like you got to be a lawyer you
argue
that's the thing man i was like okay all
right sure i can respect that so i
embrace that right i embrace my
argumentative side
uh she's like what would be like a a job
like a dream job then
and i told her i said i'd want to play
video games and
and i remember us all laughing it was
like this kind of like ah
never so matt
oh yeah sure it's like what are the odds
i'm gonna work a normal normal person
job and so
i as i grow up and i i see that there
are just people who
care about this i didn't think oh hey
when i started making youtube videos
in like 2010 or whatever it was even
before that
because i was making like skate bail
videos and whatnot like i didn't think
hey this is gonna turn into a paycheck
of any kind
um and so really as it developed and i
i just kind of wanted to have this i
think at the end of the day i really did
just want to have this platform because
i'd watch like angry video game nerd
uh i'd watch reviews from gamespot
um like they used to have like an old
gamespot reviews channel you can watch
these like vintage ones where they're in
a studio with like a television behind
them and
it's like in 360p like it's just
like wow like these are relics
and um just watching i was like there is
something here and so
i just always wanted that so really the
first and foremost thing
was it was just a desire to not work
that normal job
but also you know the second thing is
just wanting to
have that platform um
more of you wanting to be happy because
you heard these horror stories of people
working nine to five
yeah like that's not what i want to do
like i didn't want that lifestyle man
like i just
i wanted to just live a good happy life
you know games and
so that's what i was kind of going for
and i guess it worked out a little bit
but you know
it was definitely spawned mostly from
just just
the horror stories you know that you'd
hear
definitely did it and that that is so
cool because again you know at that time
like you're saying
you know it was something kind of i
would say unheard of but it didn't seem
like
something realistically could happen
because you know from that era your
parents are like
hey you're going to be this and you know
most kids you know they graduate
they kind of gravitate towards that
right like that's what you think you're
supposed to do
and that oh that's just some fun stuff
and you know you can't
really make a living out of that so to
see you transform and
and continue with that is really cool
and i want to get into your content real
quick because one thing i really respect
about it is um
you know you really champion like a lot
of original ideas you got like a lot of
unique content
i love like humanity's worst games
and then one thing recently that i know
took
a lot of work was that you and i shout
out to uh lord acg we had all like
raiding the game pass games oh just like
i'm like that had to take and he's like
you got to see it like he's got like the
whole layout
and he's systematically going through
every game
right putting it in a ranking the x-ray
rack you should try you should
try it you know giving you a brief
synopsis and i'm saying to myself as a
fellow colleague i'm like
that took a lot of work so salute to you
on that but like thank you
why is that type of content these like
so important to lower battery plays
uh man i think part of it's i look
around at people's energy level i look
at the content people do and i try to
watch too much because that's
like that imposter syndrome at least for
me it trickles in a little bit like
like man i'm feeling like i'm not doing
enough so i just have this mindset and
it's gotten unhealthy at times so i try
to i try to temper it but it's like
you can make very shiny sparkly content
but you will never outwork me that's my
mind right like
and and that's at times a little overly
competitive
let's go that's the new york let's talk
that's right
and yo you you your content may be good
but would it come to that work ethic
when it comes to putting i'll be there
every day yeah listen he's the abandoned
holy field of content
this may have you may have a little bit
more flash in your pan
but at the end of the day you're not
going to work yeah
exactly you know i think of it like a
role player or something right like any
of your any sports team you're like yeah
like
this guy does his job really well right
and so i i think of it that way i
embrace my role like i'm the rpg guys
like yeah let's let's hit the highest
ceiling for that
um because i love i love doing that like
i'm not gonna stop loving you and then i
know that like
so for me it's it's about putting in the
work it's
you know i i um when it comes to making
like those those bigger videos though
um i think it's just that i look
at times and i see people sort of
tossing out
lazier whatever pieces of content and
some people are cool with that by the
way like some people work a different
job and
youtube's their side things so they'll
sit down flip on the webcam and let that
be that
this is my full-time thing so it's like
i i i have just a very strong conscience
where it's like
i cannot escape it where if i feel like
i've i've under-delivered like i'm
disappointed myself and i'm
right never it never feels good so
i look at you know the amount of support
i've gotten on patreon
i look at the the amount of people who
have let me let me grow that's really
what
what it's it's at the core of is kind of
like
trying to pay people back because you
know i started this like i said when i
was super young so
i'm making these videos while i'm
growing up man so there's
stupid stuff i've said done
ridiculous skits and all the likes that
uh
bad takes like i've had to just grow
through them because it's like he's
young like you know
and and people were understanding with
that nowadays i don't know if
they'd be as understanding yeah all
right anybody can see you now yeah
yeah right i was like i was you know who
knows if i was a good candidate or not
yeah
but i thought i was teasing all things
yeah i was gonna say i thought it was
decent all things accounted for but i
was you know i definitely was a little
more loud mouth and all that and so
um you know even though i made my
missteps and
had been called out and everything
people still
tuned in and to me that spoke to there's
something here that
clearly people are believing me enough
to like
to to give me a chance it wasn't like
people were hate clicking going like oh
let's see what this one we're on saying
you know because i knew i wasn't like
just an idiot i was like i just i think
i've made a couple of missteps here and
and so as really i think my big
turnaround started around
2016. okay and it was just it was a
buildup yeah so
i made this kind of like i remember
sitting it was like not in this exact
chair but i was in this exact work area
i was reading my comment section i see
full out fours getting dragged again
just because it's not as good as three
or new vegas and i get ticked i'm just
like
yeah i'm like man again i'm like again
because i'm a bethesda only bethesda
content creator at this point i'm like
again they're doing it like okay
i'm gonna make a video talking about
like fallout 4 and just why
i think it's getting disrespected so i
no script nothing
i pop off right i sit there i fly off
the handle that's right um
video's still up by the way because
again because i don't run away from the
mistakes i made but i was really like
it's out there checking yeah
it's out there go look at it i don't
care you can see how much i've grown
that's what i said
that's right so it's there um and i
pretty much just
talked out my butt about pretty much how
i think
uh bethesda's being disrespected and
that that it's wrong that you think
fallout 4 is that bad pretty much
telling people their opinions are wrong
and
i think at the end of the day i could
have made a very educated argument and
people would have taken it better but
the reality is
i got lazy i sat there i just didn't
throw up a script or even bullet points
which is what i typically do to allow
free thought
and i just i just let it rip and a
youtuber by the name of rags
takes my video and he's like this is
terrible he just just
ripped it apart now i'm sitting there
it's a half hour video right the video i
posted was four minutes
yeah it was it was the maddie rose tape
for 30 minutes yeah i'm just like i'm
like
oh my god so you're seeing people write
in
um just saying like about time you got
called out it was like a pretty
it's a pretty tough moment especially
because i'm sitting there like all day
just like thinking like what do i do
what do i do right i'm like
i i get it right that's what happened
it's like i get it it was that moment of
like i needed that moment
i did as much as it sucked i needed that
moment
and so i made a video saying look
if i get where you're all coming from
right this video is also up i think it's
called like bethesda fanboys or
something like that
i was like i'm gonna be better so hold
me accountable
you can watch i understand if you want
to leave and i left it in their hands
because i was like i get it man and
i eventually i just held myself
accountable more and more and more
and i think that's what led to a lot of
growth is because i know what it's like
to be called out
and um from there it's it's just been
steadily building up hill and um
now we're in a pretty good spot where i
where a lot of people
there was a period of time especially
last year because last year was a a year
strong growth for me
where people were coming in going i
haven't watched you in x amount of years
and wow you've you've become so much
better
and that was like that approval where
you're like
you're like damn like all right thank
you i i feel like i've finally done it
right
i feel like i finally achieved
what i was setting out to do which was
like prove to people like hey i'm not
the
i'm not the immature kid anymore like i
get it like i was
but you know i've grown up and i'm not
like overly serious i have a good time
but like
i can give you an educated conversation
i can bring you the facts
yeah right i can bring you the fun like
i i can do it and
i guess it just took you know the small
group of people to believe in me when i
launched my patreon 2017
to see like 80 people sign up at that
time and be like i believe in you and
you're like
you're like 80 people like you can fill
a room with that man like that's so
crazy yeah that's a lot of people
i don't i don't think people realize
when it comes to
like even if if you're starting out
streaming you've got like 10
15 people that's a lot
like that that that is a line trying to
get into the launcher
like then you're thinking like there's
520
30 people in here though that's a movie
theater
hit those likes please and share anyways
but
i remember when we had 10 15 people in
the room
and it really was i'm the first time we
hit 100 people in a room
i think i talked about it for two weeks
now look at this man like you guys are
doing amazing that's that's what it's
all about right is that gradual build up
and if anyone ever is out there creating
content just use that as perspective
look at like you're like the room i'm in
right now man you tried to fit 540
people in here no it's not happening
like
no way like it would fill up it would
fill up an arena it's not an arena but
like
that's what's incredible about it man is
the ability to reach out to
to so many people so i've never lost
that perspective just being able to
see how many people actually believe in
me and in turn believe in myself yeah
absolutely man you know what i like i
like
that that one person that has always
been there
you know and it's a bunch of y'all but i
like like
i'm just gonna highlight one person
right i swear i
i think i can remember him for as long
as we've been doing this
smitty smith smitty's mafia is for sure
and what about you
he's he's he's everywhere like if i
throw up at kos
sweetie smith you know um if i'm on
twitter
smitty smith and you know everything and
i just say
damn these are people that it could be
anywhere in the world
that you resonate with on whatever level
you resonate with them and you have a
connection with this individual
all over and if i could like i said if i
could reach one person and have a
connection with one person i'm truly
happy
right because i look at people content
and i look for connection
or or something that ties us together
yeah absolutely i don't really watch a
lot of people podcast
i don't really uh uh do a lot of things
like live stuff like you said because
you don't want to have that same mind
thought of other people's stuff
but if i do come across your content
and i do get a chuckle i do see
something that inspires me
i feel that i owe it to you to just
check it out check it out
that like button because that stuff
means so
much to a growing conscious creator that
content creation
you know what i'm saying i just want to
jump into something else matt says that
i feel good get out of it
and you know i've noticed that you go a
little bit beyond that like i've noticed
obviously i'm not a big name at all you
know i would say i'm like
i'm like uh like a small fish in a small
pond
well my son watches you like that's the
stuff i don't like
he actually watches addict when i go
when i jump in like a podcast and i say
something in the in the chat
like the amount of energy that people
have just because i'm there it doesn't
yes like man i could i could literally
just bring your stuff and press pause
you would never know
but the fact that they see you you there
they're so ecstatic
and like what i was on uh you know i've
been on podcasts
in the past it's just like they get so
much energy because like there's nothing
more
than the people the community that you
support all the time
seeing that energy returned in some way
yeah yeah
because because sometimes it really do
be feeling like like
it's a one-way street sometimes like it
is just like
all right man i i i guess i guess i got
i got to be the gina x-man and just
raise the whole thing myself
oh thank you thank you addict
that means
man because um everybody's making a
fantastic point and i gotta
to be fair i do do the videos you know
listen i'm not gonna lie i'm not gonna
lie
that little piece that i put out to to
to whoever like
they some people say i i never even knew
that story what you were saying
and i didn't know about that character
or whatever and like maddie says
you will not outwork him me
my thing is you cannot know more
knowledge than i know about the stuff
that i'm talking about
right and i pride myself on that so i'm
not going to talk out of the box on a
character that i don't know and it won't
be here
but it would be something that i do know
that i feel that i can give to you that
i don't think that you did know because
cognito does the same exact thing matty
when he gave you your intro
he crafts these intros throughout the
week and he's digging on
research i think therefore i need to
hire him
he will get something so obscure
so minuscule that you you know forgot
about and he will bring it up
that will bring that smile to your face
and i like to say your smile is
infectious
every time you smile i'll smile
man
and i say to myself he's the greatest
host
because he does this in investigative
search
on every person and he doesn't say um
because somebody else that we perceive
as highest
he does it for everyone with the same
exact
extensive search it's beautiful what's
funny is is uh
i'm i've been working a lot on the attic
show i'll be like i'll be like what
what's what's your opinion he'll start
to say something like
i am not going as far as you
[Music]
thank you for that that means a lot um
shout out to oh yeah we got to get
someone in the room
so we'll get the chats in a minute but
this is important and the reason why
they want to brush over this because
maddie
actually resonated with a lot of points
that were me and a lot of points he said
and that the cool thing i think that you
said too is
was growth yeah and i i think
a lot of times man this is my opinion
you know in the current state of youtube
and content creation and stuff like that
or just social media
right where it's like let's just say
you know at the time i knew you and we
were conversing on social media and
during that time you made the fallout 4
video whatever whatever right
like you know you're going in and you
know they say oh bro it's not factual
this guy's stupid you know you know all
that the vitriol right yeah and
the thing that i like is that one you
took
the criticism like a man right and you
didn't run from it
and you addressed it right so that's
first that's the straight stand up so
salute to you on that right thank you
but then the thing that i i really try
to remind people
is that we're young we're growing
sometimes in the space
we're gonna say people are gonna say
stupid stuff see we're gonna say
you know they make mistakes right the
thing that i don't like
is that like because of that or you know
everyone acts like they're infallible
and then it's like oh no we can't rock
with him because
he said this this that third you know so
now he's he's canceled forever
right yeah and my thing is look at when
you allow someone to grow right people
mature
some people now some people there's some
people they're not sure and that's on
them right
but my thing is i've always believed in
that because i guess for a while from
you know south bronx and i've seen
people make mistakes in their life and
i'm saying like that
and then you see them grow and transform
into something great
but if they were never allowed that
chance and we
admit literally cut them down we don't
talk to them we don't associate with
them
because of this mistake you never get
those moments you see what i'm saying
and that's the thing i love about what
you said because
look at what it did you said it yourself
right it was important
that i needed that at the time it made
me re-evaluate myself
and then boom we got the legendary body
plays that we got right now
out here moving and shaking but i just
want to move forward i had to give you
your rose roses that's an amazing story
oh thank you i want to talk real quickly
i know this is a little that's sensitive
i know you've recently made a tweet
about it
which is um maddie plays the insider you
know
[Laughter]
you know all right let's get it let's
get it we got a subject on that and i
know you know
you could be hard on yourself sometimes
with the information that comes across
your desk
because you do you take it seriously
right but the thing
i want to ask like is the fun side like
what's someone like
the most fun thing that came across your
desk
and turns out to be true like from a
scoop perspective or whatever like what
was some of those moments
oh yeah i mean it's it's pretty rare but
uh when it does i think
kotor remake was like one i was just
like i was like you got to be kidding me
i was like it's actually happening
like yeah man yeah
that was 100 percent question
we yeah we do have a a a question from
our community from that particular topic
exactly
oh wow all right we got yeah we got a
lord slow well he wants to know you know
obviously if you can't go
too into it he wants to like we're kind
of
on scale is this breed make do you think
it's going to be is it going to like
change anything of the story or is it
but then you could try like do a one for
one with maybe slight graphic in it
but before you answer i just want to get
the extent of it he actually had a
little bit more too
slow-mo said a lot of questions for
laura madden he said he and jason
schreiber broke the leak that asperger
was doing the kotera
remake he said has you heard of they
changing the story at all or keeping it
true
to drew carpentia's vision the legend
yeah
uh that's exactly what i said at
columbus yeah they're raised
there is a a rumor at one point that
they're doing like a
like a hybrid of sorts like they were
melding
one and two together in some way which
wouldn't
timeline wise a lot of sense yeah um i'm
pretty confident they're doing it
separately so i don't know to the extent
of what they're changing the one change
i know and i've said this before is they
are doing more action combat like that's
a thing
they're doing story-wise i can't speak
on because not even like i don't want to
share anything i genuinely don't know
i i imagine if it's a remake it
should be pretty pretty close to it but
um that would just be that would
personally be my assumption
but combat wise i can't say that is
changing okay like that is a
change for sure and now salute to kotov
i'm gonna i'm on the um
on the fence right now because xm
studios just announced them po'd
dark reverend and dark malek and they're
both fighting off
and i'm on the fence and peeling this
because i have a hard line when it comes
to star wars going down that rabbit hole
i'm a darth maul fiend i stay on that i
have a whole wall of dolph moment i get
when the guys get a chance to see the
red room
they'll see it but i'm on the right room
and you would have to sit in the right
room you would have it sit there
for the red room i mean darth maul is
like the inspiration for the red room
let's go
but that dog reverend man
and dolphin i think kotor might push me
over the edge in peeling these two
for this um yeah man i
understand your love for it and i know
when it came across your desk when you
saw it
he was like i can't believe this and i
know you took a it took a second it was
like
please be real like if it's real please
be real because i get dms with stuff and
i
i'm not an insider so i don't you won't
hear me tweet out anything but when
somebody else pronounced it i'm like
yeah i knew about that
yeah but i hope i had hope in my heart
that was right
and after that that's your game
oh man i know it felt like i keep a lot
of the stuff to myself too and i
remember
it like obviously it was an open secret
at the time playground's working on
fable and i'm a huge favorite man
so like literally every time we go to e3
like i'm like
they will better be here
17 2018 one of those years i'm
pretty sure it was 2 000. he hated the
show after that
no no no we're watching it and it it it
was a bad show in general yeah
and i remember thinking to myself it was
one it might have been 2009
no because last year i was the one with
me about the theater we went in it was
19
19 wasn't it no it's the one that it was
the year he was sitting next to me
i don't know no both years it happened
but i remember 2019 particulars the one
where we did the interview outside yes
yes and i remember we walked right out
of the the
the microsoft theater it's not that
you know the presentation was bad it's
just a lot of the content that was in
there i didn't care about
so i remember sitting here cog is right
beside me that's fine addis ward i'm the
mayor you ain't allowed in
this world all day i'm sitting here he's
he's
calling someone's to the right of me
because king's somewhere doing his fan
fest though i'm sitting there and i'll
never forget
cogs like because of course look it's
spooky i was like they got it they got
to save it with fable
they got you they got to save it with
fable
man they wouldn't even show up
i know for a fact this could it was like
a month or two before the july event
last month last year he's i know for a
fact it's there
i know for a fact like it's not there
till i see it exactly
i was like i'm convinced you guys have
been trolling me
no this is real you could see my
reaction what it's fine but if
it was so cool i was just doing that for
him bro like
you gotta understand man like it was one
of the moments
it's like i'm the same way like him like
when it's something be loved like how
kotor's beloved you know for a lot of
people like you said it
you know i know how much fable means to
him and uh
and i was there to see the face in the
reaction i was like ah he got it you
know what i said it yeah
it was good it was though i wanted to
because i know we we go a little bit
long and
we got to get these topics here but two
quick questions we will find what's your
favorite um
you know podcast origin stuff and um
obviously you know what i'm saying we
got that ham radio podcast just so
you know saying oh they see you having
around the course the legend
you know and uh dustin was it earlier
you know so
origins of that and then of course well
i want to talk about
that defining do you know what i'm that
how you
and and acg say okay we're going to also
do this and then
you know in conjunction with being on
the last 10 meters we were
blessed to have the legendary the
amazing colin moriarty
in the realm and we love his movement
and we love a lot of the people on
you know that's a part of it so let's
break down podcasts like the origins how
do we get these things going
so ham radio podcast that's my baby i
started that in 2014 so it's it's had a
long history
man i mean you know i'm proud of that
show it may not be like a highest
ranking show we have a decent listener
number but
it's mostly a youtube show and i'm proud
of it because
we started off with myself uh when i had
about i wanna say 30k
40k subs lone vault wanderer now senior
community manager at bethesda in
australia
at the time he only had a thousand subs
this is one thing i've always believed
in i just want to say is like
talent town's real kind of something
that that permeates throughout this show
that we'll get into in a sec
but i didn't care hey loan you're not
this big name
talk about it you know it's like dude
give me give me the best man in the room
not the most popular man in the room
like that's what i want or whoa
you know whatever like give me give me
talent like that's what we're looking
for
[Music]
so alone i picked i'm like i want i want
to do this show with you he was in
and then one of my best friends noah who
i knew personally he's in the games and
stuff i said why don't you hop on too
like and and noah wasn't a big name so
we just make this show
we run it for about a hundred episodes
it becomes really popular it was called
hamrio podcast so it was during the fall
out four days
very bethesda-driven um and and the
numbers were insane
and it was a really good run for us you
know it was a show that
honestly because we were such good
friends we never talked gaming it became
just this tough
we would just we would be like all right
let's talk uh fallout 4 and then we'd
suddenly be talking about like our
favorite ice cream and he's like
you know and and um over time uh
lone wanted to reveal his face but he
worked at a
uh a particular i want to see he was
like a law firm involved with gaming
right so he was in the esau yeah so he
was like i can't be
on a show and uh associated uh
and at my face out there because it
shows i have potential biases
and my my rulings wouldn't be fair right
so he was like i'm gonna do this i'll
have to leave the show and it sucked but
i was like dude i want you to
you're my friend like i want you to go
live your best life so go do what you
got to do
at the same time um
noah had not really been showing up he
was sort of falling out of the show he
was kind of falling out a little bit
with it in one way but he was also
i was just saying for real like he was
getting complacent and
eventually we were just like like no
like you know it's clearing out into
this like we're just gonna
kind of move past this right so we had a
big talk about it we agreed and so it
was me and
no loan for a little bit and then over
time we get carrick in the picture
this is where yeah acg so it was us
three for for a number of episodes and
then loan was like all right you know
i'm gonna start doing this thing
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to dip now and
so now it's just carrick and i
and so this show is now completely
transformed right because it is this
just now it's a uh maddie and character
when it starts off it's completely
different so i had
a number of crossroads where i was like
man do i end this show you know because
it's not what we had started as
or is it going to get better so it was
carrick and i for a while
we're developing this chemistry um shout
out to carrick by the way for just being
open to doing this right he's a real
if you can follow the stuff that i told
you guys
i'm messy as hell
yeah just so shout out to ant-man
because he he you know he's
i didn't really tap into this too much
but one of the things that let me
believe in myself
was was working alongside people i
admire so working with colin working
with carrick
yes uh working with like i said even
loan like low maybe been small but low
and i admire endlessly so like working
with him
and many other people uh just really
built me up because it's like man i'm
with the people i
that i that inspire me and that's that's
what you want right
so me and carrick were on this show for
a while and i start to i'll be honest i
started to feel a little fatigued at one
point i'm like all right
feeling like we're we're finding our
rhythm a little bit here but
something's missing because carrick and
i are both straight shooters yes
so it was like where's the room for
something a little more fun and
part of it's because like i started to
strip a more sarcastic element for
myself
for youtube because i'm very arya i'll
jab you like me
i like to chuckle with it you gotta have
something yeah
yeah but i know sometimes people don't
get that right like
in defining duke we got a review because
someone was pissed i like made fun of
their
their spaghettios i got a one-star
review and i'm like
man damn penny yeah really and i was
like dude
are you serious but you know i'm just at
that point i'm embracing it
get that segment was that the show you
guys were saying
like grow up yeah yeah we were telling
them what that was about
this man this man said he was sitting
there playing the game he's like i gotta
build my favorite bowl of spaghetti
that's my paws
spaghettios i'm like you're a girl man
get it go go go
go welcome
right like i'm going to tell you grow up
but if you like spaghetti like spaghetti
daddy probably saying that he's got some
spaghettios in that camera
[Laughter]
to the cup because they only give you
like two meatballs
that's the most disrespectful can of
pasta you can order man
you have to get three to get like four
meatballs
shout out to spaghetti
because my mother would give us the can
and then
you look and i gotta share and it's only
yeah it's one meatball per family man
you gotta chop the meatball up and split
it out
oh sorry
um yeah so like i said you know we're i
feel like we're losing something here
and
over time i'm recognizing like i gotta
loosen up carrick is is already doing
his thing and so
as a as time goes on um last year
i'm talking to carrick and i'm like you
know thinking about ending things he's
like look i'm game for whatever right
like i'm game for for whatever you want
to do it's your show i'm happy to do it
and
you know so plus numbers are really
slowing down too and so
you know you want to be smart with like
we're doing these three-hour shows you
want to make sure like when we're
putting it out there
we're getting something yeah and
uh eventually i start talking to dustin
more and more because colin had signed
me on to do side quest videos like i
offered to him because i heard him in a
podcast say like hey
um uh like i think he has chris and
sweeney
if he's like you guys want to do videos
and they were like yeah maybe i was like
hey i'll
i'll see what if colin's up to it
because i'm interested in just talking
about other things
outside of rpgs i'm like this would be a
good event for it
so long story short colin's like yep
let's do it i start talking to dustin
more and more
legends and dustin's telling like me and
dustin had like
three different two-hour phone calls
just
getting to know each other uh because
that's the thing right i like to
familiarize myself oftentimes like the
talent i work with
absolutely and you know i could tell
there was something with dustin and i
really liked and
at the end of the day i i you know he
starts talking about like how he's doing
handsome phantom and he's just executive
work for
uh at the time colin's last stand i'm
like
he's like i got a lot of free time i'm
like would you want to join my show then
and he's like whoa he's like let me get
back to you he's like i think i'd be
down for that i said yeah dude no
pressure every friday 4 30 we just sit
down talk games
you know it's a good time and
he was game and when dustin joined our
show just had this second wind you know
we're starting to pick up more and more
um and i think it's because we've had
this circle
form this overlap form between myself
acg of course
but then last stand and their audience
has stepped in
and um we've noticed that our audience
is overlapped
here with iron lords we noticed our
audiences overlapped as well
with as always podcasts which funny
enough i've guessed it on these both
within the last couple of weeks which is
really neat but
i'm seeing more and more like wow we
have this big circle that's forming that
really just overlaps in the podcast
space and
so we got the second win and just dustin
brought this loose kind of energy to our
show that we just needed we
needed it man like we needed that talent
like he's an amazing guy
which helps of course but we needed like
a guy like dustin who would come
in and just be like screw the topic man
let's
let's talk let's talk about that that
can of spaghettios for example
ignore the like me and carrick said
straight shooters right we're gonna hit
your question we're going to hit it hard
dustin's like we'll get to that in a sec
and so we
fed off of that yes and now and now it's
just like this
much more dynamic enjoyable show yes no
brother
i hear you um i gotta i will be remiss
but i'll shout out my brother little kid
oh i always like and we were in a
similar situation and attic knows right
you know and there's no disrespect to
anyone like we love lord swat we love
you know
zero and it was just do the logistics
and stuff they couldn't
make it you know what i'm saying and
stuff like consistently and then you
know
we get solved which is again i've known
since the third grade it's family you
know what i'm saying
wow then yeah i've never solved my life
like we grew up south bronx we've
literally been in every class since the
third grade in school third you know i'm
saying we played
american together like we know each
other all of us know each other we're
family
and like king is family lit literally
you know what's in it so
i remember the conversation king and i
was just like yo
i i want you to come on i think you'd be
cool and i didn't know if he would do it
you know saying to be honest i didn't
know if he would do it
because in my mind he was always a star
he was always a person
that when we i'm gonna make him cry i'm
gonna do this
and uh it was one of those things like
you know you just
when you meet king in real life it's the
same what you get
it's and it's even funnier it's even
like i've been
lucky to have because i get the curse
yeah
thank you for respecting that rule of
the show
but one thing about is when you meet him
i swear like you're gonna fall in love
with him
and then you're gonna have the most fun
you've had in your life you're going to
laugh
the i've had the best laughs with my
life with this man you know they don't
got this one laughter
yeah we don't never thought that would
be another thing that'll be a different
thing
but it came on and me and attic looking
at it right and we're like
yo this is what we needed like and it's
like and he
he he he's a mad convict of his
what's the word conviction the man of
his conviction he stays
even if we think it's nuts we were like
but i know he believes it and i
know and a lot of times he's proven us
wrong and it's been true that's what we
call it
i mean 98 of the time he does
king does what i like to call he throws
like 50 darts
and then five will land he's i told you
all
he's also like when you mention the the
camera thing and
and you know even the shirts the logo
like getting us out of our comfort zone
mm-hmm and saying yo you gotta get okay
and we like no we're not doing this we
don't and it's
made the show better you know what i i
noticed maddie
um when it comes from the marketing
standpoint i embraced the marketing
aspect of
everything that you see in iop um and
i take credit for a lot of things that
you see
but there's reasons why because
i know when we used to sit down on
saturdays and we'd talk
if we had a camera on us oh we'd be the
greatest thing ever like
you would laugh and die yourself
but i also know that whenever i looked
at anybody podcast
and um i see little dots or the little
avatars and you got
your craft yeah a little avatar so much
and it's so nice and your little
bleeping dot so i know who's talking
it's so disgusting to me that i just
like i i can't watch
but when i see your smile see nobody
will get maddie's smile if
maddie's camera is not on
i don't care if somebody's having a bad
day they tune in to you and you smile
and they're like
man maddie's everything yeah it's better
yeah
no you're absolutely right that stuff
matters yes it matters to me
so okay me and cog was in a in a weird
space at
a point and i said if the hell yeah i'll
be on the show
hell yeah we'll do the show and i don't
miss i'm here every sunday
regardless to whatever's going on
because he knew at that point in time i
had kept my companies running and i'm
doing
a lot but regardless to what saturday's
on sundays was untouchable
but it's the dynamic that you have and
the respect that you have and i see that
same respect
on on with you and ac i see
i see it and dustin yeah the
way it moves the organic nature to it
and the way y'all rift off each other
you know it's it's a fantastic sea and
and you transition into that show in the
next show that you're about to talk
about
but it's it plays a big part in
visualization
and chemistry that you guys do and i'm
glad that you said that you felt that
something was going down
and you started to feeling a plateau and
you needed that boost of energy and then
it happened and you see it no absolutely
but continue i i
i had to be you know you got some
inspirational stuff out of me dude and i
i love it no i love hearing that because
people can tell right people can tell
when you're not into it like i don't
know how else to say it man they can
tell when you're tapering off or
when you're uninspired or when your
show's flat and
no one wants to bring that and it's like
you also don't want to bring it and fake
it right yeah yeah
let's let's get that energy it's like
you gotta bring people who are gonna get
it out of you right
so carrick 100 does and and dustin
even more so now and just these wild
loose shows and
so carrick and i have been doing this
for five four years together and
that leads us to defining duke where
yeah right like we're we're talking in i
think this talk started in september
originally started off as me and dustin
we're gonna do an rpg show and dustin's
like i don't think i'm really well
equipped for something like that and i
was like all right i get that
and the bethesda deal goes down right
looking at it and i'm like all right you
mean the cinemax dude
look at that yeah
so xbox acquires zenimax and
we see we see we see uh you see this big
pop for xbox hype and
i'm looking at the lay of the land i'm
sitting there thinking to myself like
okay they got obsidian they got
in exile oh they got all everywhere
who did that for you what what do you
want him to say sir
oh phil dominus maximus
i know you are you implying that phil's
greatness
it helped start the career of this
amazing podcast
no i know this though i know i know when
maddie saw that he's like yes
that is true you know what it is you
know what is crazy though
that microsoft body but that is the had
had a domino effect and it started there
that's dope
shout out to phil
i'm looking at it though and like i i
grew up pretty like as you could tell
with the gaming history like i
i grew up with pretty much most consoles
in my house like i didn't touch on like
stuff like ps2 and gamecube and all that
stuff but i was like
all over the place i didn't really have
an allegiance the only time i'd say i
had some type of allegiance was
it was really during the ps4 era i'd
never touched my xbox one i owned it but
i never touched it outside of a couple
of exclusives
so i was like all right me and carrick
aren't really
for lack of better words fanboys right
right i'm liking what i'm seeing
game pass looks like it's building up
they just put ea play in there
we've seen bethesda join the fold i'm
liking the studios i see
where there's interest there but there's
not this die hard like i'm gonna throw
all of my morals out the window
for this like i'm just gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna love a little
xbox podcast maybe and so i pitched it
to dustin i'm like hey man like
let's talk to colin about uh getting a
an xbox show going so dustin similar
thing here he's like i'm
more equipped for playstation and i'm
thinking i'm going to become a third
host for sacred symbols i'm not sure how
that's going to roll out though
um and so now he is the official third
host of sacred siblings so congrats to
dustin
so he definitely figured out how that
was going to work out yeah he knew it
was going to happen eventually because
he was like he was like in and out with
way too much for enjoying it yeah it's
like
yeah he was he had to be in there right
like i said dustin improves what he what
he joins is what i say
and and so um like
with defining duke um colin's like yeah
let's do it
who do you want as a co-host though and
immediately i start running through my
hat and i tell dustin i'm like
i want carrick i said i know we i said i
know
it would have some small overlap with
ham radio but i was like i want carrick
out man that's like
that's five years of chemistry yes i
said that's people
trust acg man like that's a that's a
that's like borderline a brand that you
see the certification on you're like i
know it's going to be oh yeah
this is going to be legitimate i love
that yeah like he has you know he's not
going to have the heavy amount of bias
that you see sometimes
like he likes what he likes just like
any of us but i was like i know i've
brought that sort of like this guy's
improved
to the table i think i like we also have
this dynamic of like carrick's got the
wisdom
you know he's he's a little bit older
than me where i'm 25 so i bring this
more like new age perspective i was like
i was like dude we got the dynamic for
like a
electric show and so
colin was originally worried he's like
is there going to be overlap and i said
dude if anything this strengthens both
shows i said people are going to come to
my show they're going to hear more of us
with dustin
if we have this brand overlap pretty
much i said people already love what
we're doing
you get this new energy coming into xbox
you got this new show under like a brand
that's known for amazing podcasts
i've been looking for an idea of a fresh
start you know like i was talking about
with henry like do we do this
this was kind of that opportunity for
that so colin's like look i trust you
like
that's the thing i really never had to
convince colin about anything he was
just like
he's like i got you i understand and so
in that case like it was just really in
my hands
you know i didn't have to check with him
on the segments i was doing like i just
just only thing that we went back and
forth on was the naming of the show
and the um and the logo which
his brother dagon handled oh he was just
like hey here's a couple of ideas
and he sent me like 90 plus sketches
he's like what do you want i'm like dude
yeah yeah you want can i have a week to
look at yeah
dude kills it and so everything's set up
where
colin has allowed me just to focus on
like hey i'm gonna just focus on the
segments i'm gonna think about our
how we involve patrons and listeners and
so it's this show that's really what we
get most from people
i see is number one you can tell you two
are friends
yes which is huge huge number two like
it's not just two
it's like not just two big brands coming
together two two big youtubers coming
together to make a big numbers pop it's
like these are just guys who are friends
we happen to have
sizeable channels but the other thing
was
like i said people really appreciated
like hey you guys
like certain things about xbox like i
love game pass
i'm interested in bethesda heavily i
have that rpg
kind of heritage where a lot of these
companies that are
in the microsoft fold are rpg developers
yep
yeah all right i'm saying yeah it's like
it's like oh my god that's the sauce
they grow
that's why i'm excited like people like
oh they have that i'm excited like these
are the draft picks
and so like you i have that where
carrick has
the more even keel like i'm more
optimistic i get that too like
i bring the energy i bring the like
optimism um
i'm generally not even like in by nature
like i have stuff if you watch my
channel you know like i've been critical
about plenty of things but
i managed to have like a pretty
uplifting approach
is is what i'm told where carrick's more
like i'm gonna
shoot you down into the dirt and
[Laughter]
and i appreciate that about him we just
had we had to talk about ubisoft on ham
radio that just went live because
actually as we're recording this and you
know like i'm sitting there with one
approach and carrick's on the other end
of this
the spectrum talking about it's like
that's what it's about yeah
so i really like that we bring that to
the table that's not this very biased
show like if xbox we always say like if
xbox ends up doing poorly like we don't
care
like it's not it's not our our thing
like we're just
we're here to do a show talking about
everything xbox and and pc
and yeah so a little bit of a shorter
story on that and it's just you know it
came together
colin was very supportive uh i was
really excited about it
and and now we're running that 20
episodes at this point in time and
and it's growing it's that's the awesome
part is it's not like i knew we were
gonna have like a pop at first like hey
people are gonna be into this thing
but about sustainability and right now
we're seeing it seems like we're going
to we're going to
stay strong like colin didn't give me a
term like okay we're going to see how
the first year does
he was like we're launching this show
and it was like pretty much assumed
across all parties like
this show's here to stay oh we're gonna
do it dude i mean again
love what you guys are doing love the
dynamic the honesty
you know and again shout out to colin
for for cause that's rare you know where
where
basically the non-micro management
non-hit like the hands-off process
yeah the microsoft approach yeah
you know i just saved some money do your
thing
that's a great leaders approach
shout out to that approach yeah like you
know it just to see you guys you know
what's crazy about that too is like
you said like oh the microsoft approach
and how call is like a big playstation
no but you know what listen i'm just
talking about as far as
a a great leader yes i think phil would
be a great leader
regardless to whatever platform that
he's behind
and and you is inherent in certain
leaders like
regardless to what like i'm i'm telling
you you know it would be like
the craziest thing king is if phil ever
went to sony
and it would be crazy i mean he would
fix a lot of things
i love sean layton as well
people always assume that i'm this
playstation i mean i'm in this xbox dude
but um i was different day one with
playstation
and um show maddie the scarf show maddie
the scarf
oh you talking about with this one oh no
talk about this one oh my gosh
listen i'm wearing an xbox shirt i was
gonna say i noticed that right away you
came right
it's i believe leadership great
leadership trickles down facts and they
put uh
fantastic people shout out to matt booty
uh shout out
to a lot of like aaron greenberg you
know a lot of people that
are put into places of leadership roles
and it trickles down like you said he
didn't he wasn't intrusive he didn't
tell you oh you had this
this a year to go allowed you to
flourish
and believed in you yeah and and you
exceeded
those expectations in doing that because
you didn't feel
constrained you didn't feel like this
deadline or this knife in your back
you know just gave you some stuff that
uh hey here here's a hundred uh
uh or whatchamacallit that sketches uh
which logo do you like
now i understand that's something that
was yeah pushed on you like yeah so
yeah i love this stuff he's like i drew
a hundred but i'm gonna make you choose
between
three absolute man and again to see your
trajectory to see what's going on again
the chemistry i love watching you guys
and
i love the fact that both of you in my
opinion are truly
expert reviewers of videos and i think
it's the way that
you know it's like connoisseurs watching
artists talk about these games and
catch nuances that i didn't even catch
and because of doing it for so long
you guys have this um this compatibility
as well as
you get these nuances and intricacies
that a lot of gamers won't catch
because you've been working with the
devs and stuff so salute to that man
it's like the
it's it's really a product of working
with both colin and carrick for so long
is like you just
like i i remember when i first started
talking with carrick i actually felt
very
intimidated not by his energy but this
guy knows this
so much yeah and i'm sitting there like
man
i feel like i can't hold my own and and
dustin had that for some time as well he
told me and
with with carrick and i and so he had to
adjust and
it's that awakening you know going back
to all that that you have
where i felt hey i i thought i knew
games but it's like
do what and you did but you know maybe
not to that level
and and so just working with them both
has has forced me to up my game and
taking cues from carrick on how he
reviews stuff and so
and a lot of ways a lot of people come
to my reviews because they know i'm this
sort of like
product of carrick and it's like it is
molding a little bit
incidentally it's not like carrick's
like do this do that yeah but just by
working with him
i pick up like what oh he paid attention
to that like i'm gonna look for that
next game i review and
and you just start to make all these
mental notes and it just becomes a
form of habit over the course of like i
said four or five years still sharp and
still
sharp and still and like like yeah yeah
shout out to him last point i know we're
going along last but i got to shout out
to him too as well is that
you know what i love about acg is the no
ego does not act yeah hollywood
he doesn't you know like we were humbled
when he came on we were humbled when he
shot at us i was like yo
we see a lot of overlapping i was blown
away like
to me attic knows we've had these
conversations offline
where let's be real a lot of some of
these content creators they play these
subscriber number games
and you know what i can't talk to you i
don't know i believe your message on
reddit
and you know it's not set but it's felt
you know for a smaller content creator
and one thing we pride ourselves is we
don't matter how big or small you are
if you make good content and we
appreciate it you're going to be on the
show
schedule permitting right so at the end
of the day that's what's a shout out to
hipshot to you guys because you know i
love that about you guys you know what
i'm saying like if you keep us small
you have your friendship circle you know
what i'm saying but you're not
even you put out a tweet recently like
hey i'm looking for content creators who
you guys you know recommend that you
want to come on define and do like that
is rare a lot of people hold on to these
jewels and
i you know i can't help it they keep
them yeah like you know and it's just
like
we got to uplift each other bro we could
all what i'm saying
together you know that's what people do
not realize and it's it's eternally
frustrating the reason i say that is
because
man i don't want to say oh i did this on
my own but like
having these people stand by my side
made it worth building those blocks back
up
when i fell a little bit was much easier
they took a lot of work but it was it
was easier to believe in myself
and men like if i knew like you could
have someone like myself
on colin's big podcast platform like
you'd be like you may have a hundred
listeners but like you have a chance to
get on our
show like that's kind of where i want to
take it because colin has all these
connections to the industry where he's
doing these big profile interviews i'm
like what if i
i want to tap into that too but i'm like
what if i tap into this audience that
wants to get known because
that's a don't hold us on this topic for
too long but just as an example so
people
listening know what i mean is i have one
of my close friends paul hop on he's a
aspiring game journalist
and i want to get the perspective of
someone who's like in college looking at
the games industry from the outside in
hey how do you feel about going into do
you feel confident about this career
path and we talked about this in the
state
of the industry and afterwards he had
people reaching out to him across the
entire community
from his own college even and it's like
dude that's what it's about it's like
good we've set him up we put him on a
little bit of a path here
and if we can help out even little
littlest bit right like
because it just starts with like one
reddit post one twitter post of like
someone sharing your work or whatever
and it just
boom boom from there it snaps and that's
what we're trying to set up that's what
i'm trying to set up as best as i can
brother keep doing it we're doing a damn
thing man we love what you're doing
sorry we went super long with disabled
with your history i apologize
these were important conversations i
just couldn't let it go i was like i
know we go along i don't know
what time but it's the fact that you
want to know
maddie plays yeah like right so
for for our community that don't know
maddie plays
or your community that came over that
don't know
everything about maddie plays i'm
learning about maddie plays right now
besides the
the infectious smile and keep going
that's about
three that's three that's this is three
when i tune in
and and um and i'm watching him and acg
go and i'm i'm just like this smile
no you know what it is it's because you
you won't get that and i'm sorry to tell
you
you won't get that from a little avatar
beeping this is this is
this is this is king validating
success which he's right in conjunction
with
and my dentist i guess
this is i know what he's doing he uses a
joke but this is like
see i told you kog we needed to do this
and look at what's happening and look at
maddie plays and all the guys the bigger
guy
i get right
of of some people don't want to spend on
a camera
some people want to clean up the
background some people are
are afraid of putting itself out there
you have to shed those inhibitions to
connect with people
all right you cannot hide in the closet
with a dirty tank top and feel
that this is going to be a thing it's
not it's not going to be
a thing and if you think that level of
success
that that you will achieve imagine if
you really let people in
okay imagine if you really gave of
yourself because
what you're doing with your avatar is
you're wanting from people
but you're not giving you know and i
don't care what content you make
beautiful content fantastic but give
some more of yourself
to receive because you want everybody
else to tune in with you i'll figure it
out you know it's real talk hey like i
said we had to go but we got to move on
we go we got to get at least a couple
times
all right so top five video games of all
time questions
we can't let you roll without i need the
top five i think i know two
but top five lord maddie plays video
games of all time
whoo let's go ah that's that list can be
franchises too
for franchises all right um
i'm gonna work from one up because
that's how my brain's working right now
so nice zeo republic
yes we're gonna say as a franchise i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna take the uh
the treat that addict's giving me here
because i can't pick between one and two
i'll go back and forth all day though
obviously as i alluded to earlier in the
show just number one rpg i love it to
death
doesn't get enough love nowadays as far
as i'm concerned because people are like
oh it's a classic i'm like why is every
star wars game back and relevant except
this one it's
doing stuff with it yeah i adore that
one to the
to the high heavens number two pull out
three
oh yeah i uh attic approved
vegas right
there's just something about the world
in fallout 3. and also it's
what a lot of people actually say better
but i just want to say real quick
but a lot of people actually doesn't
matter but it's like i hated fallout 3
at first now i love it like
there's that story there that makes me
love it a little bit more because it's
like man i borrowed this from a friend
i played it i was like this is terrible
and then i bought it again and i was
like i love this
and i like it when it wasn't yours yeah
yeah i guess i guess that's the case
right shout out to your dollars
mattering
[Laughter]
three next what we got number three uh
sly two band of thieves
love me some sly cooper man that is
waiting for that remix
yeah dude they pretend it doesn't exist
man i made a whole video
yeah life and death of sly cooper if
anyone's interested in it you want to
see someone a grown man
complain about a raccoon thief for 20
minutes plus
by all means you'll see me dress up as
them like i love it
don't worry about it yeah that's what
everyone wants next is jack and daxter
that's what they want
number four persona 5 royal wow
just just
masterpiece good game i've always told
cognito that like i like y'all cause i
like a dragon
but persona like there's something about
that battle system
like like i feel like persona could be
what
like final fantasy could be where
persona is if they wouldn't have tried
to chase the bag for the casual market
and change
up their their format so drastically and
yeah people are the atlas is like we're
going to do what we've always done we're
just going to do it
we're going to always evolve it and make
it better yeah you're right no doubt
yeah
oh the lord of bethesda has enjoyed
himself lord acrobat
is joined by the confined to see if
lord bethesda himself has come down from
heaven from god howard's throne
to bless us from the multiverse to make
sure lord maddie
is in pocket with the right you're
talking about the throne that's under
the field
you meet the guy that works that's the
name
of his franchise
because this is a fellow bethesda lover
of rpgs
and it's good to get these brothers
together on a podcast yeah but get
caught
in already so we got again we got
personal four we got the fall out joint
you know what i'm saying what was the
first one i missed the first one real
quick what was that the the first one
was oh knights
that's a republican yeah all right so we
got three franchises
i think we were on four four four four
yeah we did slides
yeah five is tough man because i guess
you could do persona in general for four
because four golden would be in that mix
so
we'll just do that and and five i'm
gonna throw i'm gonna throw mega man in
there
that's uh just as a series just yeah
that is
pokemon broke my heart
favorite console of all time
and why
dude back exactly back light life
changer
got to play it was fun my parents didn't
even know
what's funny is i bet you didn't even
know that i don't know what's going on
but i love that y'all love it
you know what i didn't care about that
because i always had that little bendy
light
that was down
i understand but listen i used what was
available to me i i used that as well
i used that i used to use street lights
see maddie remember when i asked you you
said you found a purple one
did they have the bendy light yeah i
know she talked about yep
ms3 tremendous gaming we gotta
extinguish some thomasville salute to
eggman for pulling up i'm going to
skip last week's post stuff because we
got a new paul coming up but i'm trying
for the sake of time
we gotta move on a little bit we got to
get into these topics man so let me get
these super chats yes
apologies you're right let's get to
super chat we do that a lot we've got
about 10 or so okay
so we got a five dollar super chat from
smitty smith it's actually the great
fun jay fonz is an absolute pillar of
the community
yes shout out to lord fawns man we got a
uh two
super chat from akw what's up lords and
maddie plays nice to see you
nice uh we got almost 600 people
i messed it up again but like i said
we're going to move right past on that
not going to be here long so i'm just
going to say this is real quick okay
they weren't here long so they hear me
butcher their name that's fine
got it to the lords y'all it's fire as
usual don't attack dez because your
hardware is just a
oh my god i got you don't worry
we got a five dollar ship jeff from one
bad [ __ ] played mass effect 2
for the first time ever rearranging top
five of all time
would have to be a lawyer to argue this
is better than
well i mean we did have a lawyer arguing
we did that shot the whole glory
greetings on the lord's day i've been
listening to you guys for a week and
loving the vibes on ps4 but now
king has me looking at the series x on
amazon
it's sold out we're going to keep but
get over there to that xbox live you got
to find other supervision kdk
hello to the lords on this fine sunday i
am looking forward to the lord's day
thank you all for the love
for the last each week thank you we got
a two dollar super chat for pixel bit g
i think gate empire and control were the
best work
yeah though i definitely hate empire you
know i've never played jet empire i
always get attacked
right now right yeah
so we gotta find all this trailer trap
from brit uh brigham
probably butchered that too like i said
it's okay your thoughts on the scarlet
next uh
nexus demo has anyone played that
besides me no not yet
that's some addict stuff it's it's okay
i feel like
it's definitely it's got a place it has
me
actually looking at it like oh maybe i
would actually buy this i don't know if
i'm there yet
but before i play yes banger it's it's a
demo
it's like but i mean isn't it going to
come in the game that's game day one i
don't know
oh i have a theory it will but yes no i
feel like it fits
they revealed it on their own stage
you're right everything that was at that
show they told people everybody
everything that was at that show is
coming to game pass
so if y'all want to go purchase and you
don't want to listen to the fine print
that's on you
i i i will say one thing real quick
because we're going on too long i do
think that before the demo zero chance
to be buying it
after the game pass obviously i'm
playing it but uh
after the demo you got me up about fifty
percent like i liked a lot of the
aspects i was seeing i was on it no
maddie i love you give us star force
back
wow all right that's some passion right
there there we go so we got to fight all
these troops from dan lorenzo
i butchered that we're moving past that
fanboys turned gaming into a cult and
now they're developing into weird
tribalist console worshippers they spend
more time tweeting than gaming
talk about it definitely don't don't
agree with you he owned something with
that yeah we got a five dollar super
chat from big cloud gaming salute to the
realm what's up lords
big clown we got a two super chat from
rrd defining duke plus iop
my sunday xbox podcast
yeah what time we might have to get both
of them yeah yeah we might have some
shows
we got a five dollar super chat from
scrub nurse i definitely got that one
right
shout out to the maddie and lords enjoy
the content always keep up the great
work you guys are true inspiration to
the community
the book of acts
okay so uh we got a two dollar trip trap
from mel wizzy
uh ariel knights never yelled best
runner ever questioned
shout out to support the uh boy he's gay
i'm so happy to be
happy for him aerial night never has
released on play
it looks like it's been very successful
we got those too
is the goat of rpgs i think it's one of
the best but i don't know if i would go
go like it is definitely one of them
i mean you you said uh you you said one
of the things that got you in
uh jrpgs was uh final fantasy
he just gotta let that go he's never
gonna let that go he's gonna
let that go he's better he's gonna hold
that one until further notice your gamer
card is with me
oh my god oh we gotta find out from
keller 9000
hello lord sorry i'm late i am not
worthy gif but
i mean it hope everyone is good
absolutely
and we gotta find out super chef reggie
mobile nine salute to the lords maddie's
in the round man y'all killing it
no doubt the legend and then that's all
i have i think
though we had two people that joined so
later on we got to salute them everybody
throw the crust up i believe one of them
i've been throwing up the grip yeah
throw up the crash we i forgot the other
day if you could find the other
gentleman that
joined or uh misses that joint please we
gotta salute them put the questions
yeah yeah yeah we got to shout them out
when we can because
we got three more please go go so we got
i have to see like i'm on the actual
monetization thing so i have to reset
every time
uh so we have file instruments from jj
edwards
from uh nz i assume that's you guys new
york or news no
nz news illumina i don't know what's
what's
i don't know that's just people shout
out to the co-host not knowing continue
shout out to him shout out to him what's
up lords we're hoping
to see saint rose and uh crimson desert
at e3
everyone else excited for these games by
the way skyrim is the goat
i'd have to say skyrim one of the goats
i don't know
skyrim is good yeah skyrim is good i
just feel like the the rpg's was
drastically reduced from its
predecessors but we're not gonna go
there
shout out to kingsfield yes we got a
five dollar stretcher
uh from uh paco luigi back from walking
the dog
and gotta uh shout let's go atlanta rain
i don't i i assume that's something with
baseball i don't know
overwatch correct i have no idea okay
no idea over watch league has the june
joe's the next two months any of y'all
watching
i don't think anyone here cares about
overwatch i do i like overwatch
but i'm just not watching league of
legends i'm taking a long break
oh nino boycotted overwatch for three
years so if he says anything he's wrong
he's still mad about 2016 game awards
yeah i don't know
i'm in my feelings yes we got a from
drunken one ninja
couture versus dxx is as the go rng
rpg okay i i th that that's that's
that's
i'm sorry i'm not gonna sit hand cap
time
let's get moving we got stuff to do we
got topics yeah we gotta
we got these topics that's all that's
right that's it all right let's get it
so let's get into it all right first
again shout out to a man who has pulled
up lord but that's himself god howard's
only son begotten son
has pulled up good to see you brother
it's been a minute you
are family from day one we love having
you in the room
so um let's get into it man fun show
starfield
starfield is back in the news man one of
the most highly anticipated bethesda new
ips i feel and um it's in the news once
again
man this time courtesy of lord jason
tribe who we had in the realm
last week with some updates so i just
want to repeat what he said so um
pretty much looks like he was responding
to someone on twitter another content
creator
he said look rumors like this keep
floating about but star
wars star wars star field is nowhere
near
fraud and already can't even i lost the
name oh yeah look at you
according to several people familiar
with development it'll be at e3 but the
planned release date i've heard is way
later than people expect
sharing this so that folks keep their
expectations in check then he continued
to go on and say
what people might not realize is the
bulk of bethesda game studios including
the maryland office was working on
fallout 76 when it launched
starfield's team was very small until
2019 rumors that the game was planned
for 2020 or fought into production there
are just not true so this kind of
created a storm obviously we've heard
various
storm that that's an understatement yeah
field is two storms in my opinion and
i'm gonna let maddie jump in the first
you know was it exclusive or not right
and that was a big thing a lot of people
were you know
is it you know is microsoft definitely
gonna you know share the wealth so to
speak and put this on
on playstation and that you know a lot
of people have got in front of you
yourself acg and stuff like that got in
front of that as well
and then the second part comes down to
release date and um i want to start with
you lawmaker because um
obviously you know you may have made a
tweet recently you know
and i i had to i had to respond back
because i thought you were a little hard
on yourself but
you know i am as pretty as you all but
you're very passionate about this
subject so my question is
what are your two part questions what
are your thoughts on this potential
late 2022 release of starfield and then
second
which is something i had to ask and i've
been having this conversation in the
xbox community is this a major
disappointment
for the software lineup if it doesn't
hit 2021
normative floors or starfield uh
late 2022 is you know i'm sure we'll tap
into it a little bit but
it's interesting because it was like the
opposite of what
i would say 99 of the industry was
reporting so
yeah i don't even think you could really
completely i was right there with you
maddie i have people tweeting me saying
he was wrong you told me this you told
me that i was like
first off i can't help that you you you
listen to me
i yeah so like i said
we'll get into it more and more but
across those reports
including stuff i've heard and i said
like was always oh well
ex keep an eye out on fall 2021 they are
aiming for that but it can always slip
into 2022.
for me if jason was just like it's 2022
i'd be like all right
news news is news yeah but late 2022
kind of changes things
i you know i wonder let's go
it can sound it can sound bad at first
but
i think there's we don't know what
starfield is right now and
and so i look at it as like man there's
so many other great games coming out
there's gonna be other great game pass
deals and
when you get the first party stuff i
think starting with halo infinite they
have the chance to get this
rolling quarterly release that
is a lot more appealing to the general
consumer
so if starfield needs a little extra
time and they're like hey we're going to
have
halo infinite in the fall and this is
speculation by the way after this point
but like we're going to have towards the
horizon in the beginning of 2022
like in in february and then we're going
to have wolfenstein 3
later on in the spring and then summer
we're gonna have
starfield and then we're gonna have in
the fall fable it's like
dang you've just rolled each part of the
season with a big release that's day one
game pass
that's not accounted for the third party
stuff that they may work out so to me
it's like
it makes a little sense i think it's
exciting on that front
and i think it's easy to get
disappointed because like a lot of
people i'm not excited about starfield
i'm like
super curious though yeah you know
they've worked on fallout elder scrolls
fallout ellis gross they've just gone
back and forth on that
this is bethesda's 18 man this is the
todd howard team in maryland like
they do the best work and that that's
that's what i want to point out too
maddie is like i do see
i do think to a point there are people
that type in this game up more than it
should be hyped
but like for sure to that same point
it's like look like
it's i'm at that point where they have
to benefit the doubt from me
like but i'm not at that point where i'm
like i need it now like you know what
i'm saying
i think the cut it's like i was saying
you know people
love to give clout to companies like
naughty dog
they make amazing games like look 76 i
get it
first off their core studio didn't even
100 make 76.
they helped with certain sections of it
correct it was i think at austin they
were the ones that made it
yep so and that that's the part that
kills because it's like
besides 76 and you could kind of remove
that out of the equation because they
didn't really make that game
it's like all their games have been
either game of the year game of the year
contenders
so it's just like with that kind of like
i do feel like they they're
up there with that naughty dog type of
thing where it's like look sir some of
our games are buggy we'll admit that
yeah but they're always fun and they're
always
game of the year game with your
contenders that means that means the
whole industry for the most part loved
our games like
so i feel like star feel sure it's not
an elder scrolls it's not a fallout
but because it's made by that studio i
feel like they do they should get the
benefit of the doubt that
that that could be a good game like no
continue maddie i'm
dying to hear you know what what you
feel about that and then
you know the reason why i asked the
second part is because you know i've had
these discussions with people in xbox
circles and they're like
oh that's a major l and and and
yeah you see what your face did that's
what my face did
right but i want to hear it you know
from other people to say am i
bugging out because you know because not
i shouldn't say all people are saying
this you know it's
just a few a lot of i'm saying some of
the hardcore some of the hardcore
because they really i guess maybe
excited for it or whatever whatever
like and it's just like whoa you know i
was gonna be here on fours again oh no
you know what i'm saying yeah no they
they want the one-two punch to kick off
the year right say okay
now xbox is coming in we're starting off
and doing like okay here we go
we got starfield and halo infinite to
kick like this end of the year
and it just kicks off the rest of the
season that's what we want we
get it good yeah no i feel i feel that's
that's what i'm curious about
like maddie's thoughts on that like
where are you at with that thought
process that if it doesn't come out this
year which it may not
you know this lineup for 2021 is not
that inspiring and
more of the same yeah that's the problem
i think is
the bigger l i want to emphasize to
anyone listening is if starfield came
out it's bad
that's the l that's the l it needs to be
a good game first there there is no l
if it's a good game that's the l then
actually
that's that's the l that actually
damages microsoft not getting delayed
absolutely what is kind of damaging i
think
is you hear last fall oh we're going to
release halo infinite because
the delay as all of us know we get to
the next fall
and if and of course we're going to see
other little third-party exclusives and
and and kind of things that the id at
xbox like we're going to see the ascent
you know they just launched i think the
wild at heart was like an id and xbox
game passed
like they're gonna have these little
things but of course to
to build your your your infrastructure
and and your fan base you need to have
those big launches
i think yeah there is a fear that
there's a familiarity like
look at all those franchises i named you
know you're going to get wolfenstein
we've seen a bunch of entries of that
you're going to get halo we've seen a
lot of that and three four three
confidence isn't high on them although i
like what i'm seeing a little bit
screenshot wise and their transparency
i'm liking that but
we haven't seen the game running since
august so
you're throwing forza in there and it's
like all right you know these are all
things that
we know what to generally expect whereas
with fable
a reboot it seems like which is from a
new team
um that's exciting because that's new
starfield especially is exciting because
it's new i think that's where the
disappointment comes from is this new
thing that seemingly could have had that
big one-two punch
right which microsoft did want like they
they are not
probably going to do that it's it's
interesting because
to kind of follow up on jason's reports
i think this is really important context
that not enough people are
are hearing um is so
obviously myself and a lot of other
creators out there
uh and and websites like windows central
gaming and
and just across the board right i don't
need to name names or anything we were
all like yeah
look for fall 2021. right jason comes
out really good track record of course
does great work and goes like hey late
2022. so i
sit there and as a reporter i'm like i
need to know what happened
because this doesn't make sense that
it's not just me like this one loudmouth
youtuber
yeah there's a bunch like jeff multiple
people yeah jeff gruff at one point
said it he's got a great track record um
yeah like a lot of big names that if you
want to throw me to site fine i don't
care i'm not like
the insider i have information that i'll
share about it
i'm putting that on you all right i'll
take it
you know but i i'm looking at i'm like
there's way too many people who are like
walking back right now all of a sudden
right like but i'm gonna give you the
reason why
yeah um no no okay no no
after you finish i'm gonna give you the
reason why everybody's walking
everything back
and there's a very distinct reason that
nobody's looking up again all right i'm
i'm excited to hear because like
i so like i saw jeff grub do it i
started to say like hey um because
guy reached out to me he was like hey
it's looking more and more like 20 22.
he didn't say late he said looking more
like that okay let's see put it out
first i'm like yep you got it first like
i'm gonna let people know when
when it starts to get reported again
like who brought it first because i
think it's really important
because we don't see enough in our
industry anyway off topic so i reach out
to jason right
like i email him occasionally when when
stories happen and
mostly with kotor as i reach out to him
like hey jason hope you're doing well
um i've seen so many people reporting
2021 myself included
um you're saying late 2022 i said here's
the track record of my source i talked
about kotor i talked about microsoft and
lucasfilm i was like
he's pretty accurate he's you know been
on the ball
you know i have a couple of them i said
did
do you know because he said he talked to
the developers i'm like do you know
something internally i'm like did
something does that be strife or damning
it's just like did
something occur that changed not knocked
it back so jason
says to me hey maddie i'm going to leave
it at my tweets thanks for reaching out
i'm like all right i'm not entitled to
this information i'm assuming
he's gonna have like an article ready
yeah clearly yeah then
buddy of mine sends me posts he's making
on reset era with the context i was
asking for i'm like okay i don't really
know
what's going on there yeah i was like
yeah
whatever i was like okay okay sure uh so
i see it and i'm like
this is actually really important to the
conversation because he's like
for what it's worth the most important
thing here is he's like for what it's
worth he's like it seems like what
people were reporting on was the
microsoft side of things where he's like
i talked to developers i'm like
that makes a lot of sense when you look
at what happened with halo
it'll infinite they said oh we're going
to get this out at the end of 2020.
right here we're talking fall 2021 they
were a year off
right this if we're hearing it from the
microsoft side of things
it's like okay that makes sense why
we're hearing microsoft because none of
us said
it's going to happen right right and i
can yeah for a fact anyone can check all
my work
all of jeff's work everyone's we were
all like hey this is something that they
want to do right there's a difference
between desire and actually
you making some definitive statement
like it's definitely coming like what
you've done pretty much
just to clarify you're saying that we're
hearing
microsoft's goals of of a team yes we're
not here and the developers like
this is the realistic date yeah it's
going to come exactly
and that happens a lot that happens a
lot where these like developers
are like we heard a lot with cyberpunk
right they're like oh we're going to hit
april
and everyone internal like releasing
april 2020 and everyone internally in
the city
was reportedly like what there's no way
we're ever going to hit
so i'm imagining microsoft was like we
want to have our one-two punch and
that's
kind of like the word that got to them
and bethesda's probably sitting there
like we're not going to hit that at all
right so that's personally
based off what jason's saying what i
heard that's how i felt
now i put out a tweet i was just like
you know because it was kind of sitting
with me where no one was really hanging
over my head but i'm about
accountability i'm about
i'm about like making sure i'm straight
up honest with my audience and i was
like hey look like i know
i i i was very clear like 2022 was
always an open door
but i said i will say i beat the 2021
drum loud i was like keep an eye out
like it's a good chance
right or it's a chance rather i was like
you know it can't happen
i was like i understand being allowed on
that and if you felt mislead sure
a lot of people couldn't you cogneo you
all were really nice to me
like for you on that i couldn't but you
put yourself on a snake up there like
that now we don't because no one else
was that's the other thing is i'm not
trying to be a martyr but no one else
was everyone was like
i never said i'm like look come on like
a lot of us say 2021 come on man like
let's be real you'll be able to internet
never forgets that that's why when
people came at me
i was like look man i can only tell you
what i'm hearing like i
i'm not the developer i didn't make the
game
to matty's credit it was always that
caveat look this is what their intention
is you know
covert preventing or whatever you know
situations things may change but what
we're hearing for right now
is this you know what i'm saying but
continue
yeah and so a lot of people are really
nice about it um
you know and and it doesn't take away
from the other reportings i've done but
i was like hey if you're gonna take it
with a grain of salt like i get it which
people should be doing
anyway even with someone like jason like
things change right there's
i imagine there's no no no offense to
him i imagine there'll come a day jason
will be wrong and
should it destroy the the credibility
exactly it's like no
no it shouldn't you know have your
opinion on jason and everything whatever
but like you know it's
if he's wrong about this just like if
i'm wrong uh and
many other people were wrong about this
like i'm just saying if jeff grub says
something about elden ring y'all are
going to be listening
like if i say something about kotor
people are probably going to be
listening like
i hope that's the case still because it
shouldn't wipe away everything we've
done because for the most part we were
reporting accurately what we had been
told
and jason talked to developers which a
lot of people have access to and
he got the updated take and it's like
there you go you know what it seems like
maddie it seems like all of us
we not necessarily have the same source
but at least our swords have the same
source
it's all coming from the same faucet
real quickly because i gotta shout out
the home team uh we will get the rest of
them
shout out to lord saul in the building
the legend the lord of clarity
apologies for my absence i just wanted
to show some love to the family and
maddie
love his work and so happy for his
success on him and duke
didn't want to miss this one love y'all
i'll see you there we'll catch up
we'll catch up because you didn't say uh
the super chat's the way we like them to
say i'm just joking
wow i got it i got a ball of added to
get them around
all right then you can read the right
no i love you the sovereign touch
exactly the software but i hear what
you're saying
salute um i want to get anchorman on
because again
you know angerman has been in xbox live
party chats for me
for years and i'd love this man's
passion for bethesda
like there's phew outside of maddie's i
don't know
that i know that rep i mean he would
have the funniest memes we would go at
it he would tease me over destiny
but i always respect and i remember when
the deal went down and how happy i was
to see his enjoyment you know saying
that but that's just what myself so
i'll start off i called you like at six
of them yeah you called me at six in the
morning bro
i'm like yo this is great i can't
believe this right
so i thought i initially thought someone
died yeah i was like
what is going on i woke up to like 10
missed calls
kids smooth messaged me like there's a
other
and what's funny is is when i wake up i
don't check none of that stuff bro it
was a
moment the zenimax like like we said
king the zenimax acquisition
because they said the building don't
just
didn't go they didn't go purchase a pair
of jeans they went and purchased
the store fed up fit
how excited were you for star field and
then again your thoughts on that and
then also
with these potential rumors right of
late 2022
you know is that a disappointment for
you for the 2021 lineup
uh i'll repeat what maddie said how can
you be disappointed with something you
don't even know what it is like i
there's just you know star feel like
i've been telling you guys about star
field for last like just for years i
remember maddie talking about it on his
videos i've
we've been hearing about this thing for
a long time we still don't know what it
is all we know is that it's in space
and it's like i'm curious i'm super
curious like
i'm just not i can't be excited or
something i have no idea what it's about
so i'm right am i disappointed
how could i be disappointed with
something i don't know fair enough i
mean
so for me it's kind of like that now in
terms of like sources and stuff
i i know a couple people and they are at
bethesda
but for me like if i don't hear anything
right
i i don't i i follow a couple hard fast
rules when it comes to whole all the
insider thing
um normally if i tweet hashtag insider
i'm just making up stuff
for fun but um other thing is i don't i
don't talk to randolph thor
because every time we talk something bad
happens
i have not talked to him since 2018 shut
up
he's like you know it's funny ironically
that's when they started turning things
around
like it was um like the last time he and
i had like a real conversation
was when they canceled scale bound keep
that in mind
i saw the game it wasn't all that um
when it comes to that that's one of the
rules i follow the other one too is if i
don't hear anything from that bethesda
contact
yeah i don't i don't put any stake in
anything okay i'm not fair that fair
enough
i get your dad let's get um addict i
know you have a couple thoughts that
king's gonna
say his bars are gonna get even more
bars on the situation
disappointing is it out no 2020 no it's
not an l
now it being delay is not a l but it
will be kind of an l
if halo comes out and it's an l so you
know
how how could it be delayed if it was
never given a release date
of part two well you get what i'm saying
like regardless what was it
said and what was not said oh the most
the entire industry was satan was coming
out in 2021
so that that did kind of give yeah
expectation that
yo when everyone's saying it chances are
it's right
you know it is what it is something
happened something with the development
cycle i don't know but
but for the the expectation was it was
coming out this year
right yeah i mean sure that that only
goes off twitter because that's the only
people who really knew stuff like that
uh-huh but it's like you know
people really expected that halo that
star filled
that forza like when i was told that you
know it's probably getting delayed
it didn't hit me hard i was like well
you know i don't want
my thing is on one of the cyberpunk
right i think
it's the cyberpunk effect but it's not
what you're about to say about the state
of the game
it's more that during covid people just
wanted one game
just give us something to latch on to
and everybody is a community get on
board with right
and everything got delayed pushed back
there was just nothing on the xbox side
for just something for people just to
really
enjoy and jump on to and like people
want starfield to be that game
yeah yeah i uh i caused some flack as
well
by a couple of years for for using the
word delay and i think the reason that
terminology is creeping in is because
for us as people who are hearing things
and not even that just seeing reports
there's an expectation created of like
2021 possibly
and when it's not that it's like well it
got pushed back and i think that word
just slots in like i used it
really i wouldn't typically use it but
to me it's like there's some type of
pushback somewhere so it's been delayed
because the same thing happened like
with uh with mass effect legendary
edition remember jeff grubb was repeat
reporting out reporting on reporting on
it and he's like it's been delayed
people were like how can it be delayed
if
we don't know what the release date is
it's like there are there is
such a thing as like internal delays
but yeah it i think push back is a good
word because it was technically pushed
back
yeah yeah absolutely this is great stuff
i just feel like delay has a negative
connotation sometimes so i i totally get
why it's not the right word yeah
it triggers them they get afraid yeah
i'm sorry
but i mean when it comes down to it's
like look like am i a little
disappointed i didn't play it a little
sooner
maybe but it's just like maybe after e3
goes and if they show it really good
and if this happened then after i seen
the game then
maybe a little bit but yeah
that would hurt yeah i can't put my hand
on something
and be disappointed on something but i
don't even know what type of game it is
i'm excited that they're making it
because it's a new ip and they've made
some of the games that
have really you have an assumption on
what it is right
yeah you know what it is it's like fall
out in space
it's you have an assumption that you
want that flavor
you have an assumption see if it's me i
would personally want starfield to take
like
like an out-of-world approach right
worlds okay but i don't think they're
doing that i think i don't think so
yeah i think it's going to be more of
like flying manually and stuff i don't
know we're not getting
i i have dreams as well but i drink
when it comes down to it you know i feel
like
20 21 regardless how you feel about
forza uh
horizon 5 because i have a great strong
feeling that's coming out
regardless how you feel about halo i you
that's obviously coming out you know and
halo's gonna come out
hopefully average i mean that's the bare
minimum right yeah
let's hope it's not halo five i
actually liked halo 5.
it's just like when it comes to halo
it's like that should be enough
like we can't act like just because halo
isn't the colossal titan it used to be
and it stood on every mountain that it
ever had
that it's still not a mountain it is
though people are going to play
as long as that multiplayer is in sync i
get it campaign's important it
is that multiplayer is just going to
keep people in that ecosystem
people are going to have stuff to play
along with all the games that's going to
drop this holiday
like we didn't need starfield there we
wanted star field
we want we the reason we want star field
is not like other than the cyberpunk
thing
is also too it's like we want to see a
return on investment on that
does that exist that's what it is we
want we want to see it big we want to
see it now
none of my money went out though this is
the craziest thing like
it's no we all right see this okay
i wear this listen not one of my
billions went there
so i just had to carry on
all right so i'm i'm i'm okay
this is the let me say something real
quick for you though like i think
anchorman's referring to
look the investment into the xbox
ecosystem if you didn't necessarily
maybe die you got that it's game pass
can you let me finish my segment yeah
but
so so you don't think that game pass
doesn't have any relevancy whatsoever to
buy but that's
these games this has nothing to do with
it listen i'm gonna give you
exactly the gift and the curse you
better get everybody's
yeah and then you're gonna look at him
and be like damn this dude's right again
all right this is the gift that occurs
playstation has been doing this for
years
and when when we heard of the so-called
delay of a delay of something that never
had a date
um you also give me the e3 2016 attempt
no no no i'm talking about the the
expectations of the individuals that
feel that they are owed something right
all right we are in a now culture so
everybody wants things now
right it's never been like that but
at the same time you heard about the
so-called delay of a game that never
been announced to be a release this year
you heard about the delay of god of war
where is those ls for that right where
is that energy for that
but we're still internally going back to
this because
it's expectations of individuals that
feeling that they're owed something
you expect like anchorman said a return
on investment
of something that you didn't put in for
to come out to justify
the purchase of a company that they feel
that they need for game pass
right right i will agree with you that
that there is a lot of like double
standards going on oh no it's a complete
god of war was literally announced as a
2021 guy
and we're almost confident it's getting
pushed back so i will get it's been said
already
so now we called it being pushed back
when it was announced
right no that's that's a delay now
game pass is the gift and the curse it's
like a soup kitchen
you're not going to give all your great
meals in one day you got to stretch it
out
right so you do have flight simulator
that's coming out and people not going
to act like that's a great game
it was a great game on pc coming over
and it's going to be a milestone when it
gets to the series consoles
right so that game has to have some life
in that space
right right and then it's little titles
that you've purchased for time
exclusives that have to breathe and day
and day
in game pass right now you're going to
drop
forza which is a great title it has to
breathe in game pass
you are going to drop halo your biggest
halo
in the 25th anniversary of halo at the
end of the year
that has to breathe in this space right
now you have a game that you don't need
to
rush that nobody understands what it is
and the expectations for this game is
put on by
individuals that don't have a
controlling stake in microsoft
microsoft has a controller and microsoft
right so
that game will come out when it has that
space to
breathe in game pass it's a gift
and it's a curse but you're not gonna
get two bangers in a month
you're not gonna get two bangers right
back to back you're going to get a
banger
and we've always gotten this we've
always got a banger per quarter
it's financials that go into this people
this is not something
that happens uh by happenstance you
don't see
sony actually and i don't care what
nobody say they held ratchet
and clank until the user base got to a
spot
where they can be comfortable for loss
and they can be comfortable on return of
investment on that ip
right so if they yeah in january
if if they were dropped in january it
wouldn't have sold as much it's going to
sell in june
they're starving right now right return
came out
it that sold to whatever numbers it was
going to sell to
if there's no pandemic or something i
think return comes out a little bit
earlier
i think if consoles sell at the rate
that they should be selling at with the
no transistor problems
that they release games at a different
cadence
the games that we're getting now is in
the cadence according to the
the situations that we are in but game
pass
is a gift and it's a curse you're going
to get these games here
but they need time to breathe so when
they said starfield is not coming out
this year and everybody said oh they're
going to need a one-two punch
you want it to be a one-two punch right
that's something that you want it to be
microsoft wants it to be a longevity
thing
because remember again the platform
isn't the xbox series consoles
the platform is game pass and once game
pass is have
shows that longevity and these games can
breathe in there
you'll start to see the cadence with all
these uh developers producing these
games
the games are going to come it's just
over a period of time right
now for you let me jump in um fun
conversation love where all this is
going
um i want to hit valley with this
because i think he might appreciate this
i i think for me where it bothers me
with this doom and gloom talk about 2021
because of the starfield potential
situation in 2022
it's like maddie we we batch fans right
as a met fan you know me and you you've
been a fan of a team that had
an off year you know a lot of times
right
and it's like i think what it is is we
know the struggle
and we know the pain and we want the
success immediately we want to turn
around
immediately right so it's almost like
this bad dear
bad news bears mentality that takes over
like oh you see
this here comes another you know kind of
thing and to me
it's like i don't subscribe to it with
this generation with series x from what
i've seen so far
right to king's point yeah i mean am i
disappointed as a hardcore gamer that
it's not there
potentially not there this year yes
selfishly i would have loved it it's
it's sci-fi that's my genre it's a new
ip
i want to see what bethesda can do with
this new ip we don't know nothing about
it but i'm
i'm hyped about the potential of the
game in this
universe that i like especially playing
mass effect right now i got the sci-fi
fever right man like
yeah we're excited kind of thing so i
get the disappointment thing i think for
me
the main issue that a lot of xbox gamers
have
is i call it the big mac large fries in
the shape the forza
the horizon and you know what i'm saying
and and and
the gears and i get it you know so we
love those games but you want to have
that variety but
the thing that's bothering me that i'm
seeing from a lot of gamers and i'm
hearing this oh
you know we can't use the colvade excuse
you know what i'm saying because
you know it's not an excuse and it's
like this is a pandemic
a global pandemic that's not just
affecting xbox it's affecting
all studios some studios that we've
heard internally
attic that have come to a dead stop and
had to adjust
you know what i'm saying as far as
adapting and i'm saying that this is
starfield's case i'm just saying in
general
as a whole right so that's like i said
cognito people say you
you know pandemic citing the excuse so
it shut the world economy down but it
started
excuse me okay collaboratively motion
cap being in the team
all these things right and to king's
point you know
i mean excuse me anger man's point it's
like we got to remember
even god of war you know even everyone
doesn't matter microsoft nintendo sony
everyone is dealing with this because if
you really be real about it
there's not a lot of original ips right
now that have been dropping in this new
generation
so that's the thing and then the other
thing i hate is like
gamers can't have it both ways right
gamers can't say
yo you mad you criticize the development
how in the hell did they release
cyberpunk
like that right how in the hell did
return have this issue or i don't want
to help
you can't say that the game needed more
time to cook right
it didn't they could play at the dev
right but they'd be bad be like yo
microsoft got to hurry up get these
bangers out just that we're taking this
one
you can't have it both ways and that's
what they've
been up to i think individuals they
would have
halo drop forza drop spar field drop all
the same month
all the game right after each other
and and this this is how we're going to
live it this is right here
that's not just state that that is not
sustainable
again you know i think for me you know
and i get it for the people who want the
new ip i get it
but but like king is saying we can't act
like when forza horizon 5 potentially
drops right this year
halo infinite potentially drops this
year
we can't act like that's not going to be
a movie
marketing blitz wise regardless to what
happens
we hey regardless like i'm with you
maddie on halo 5. but i remember when
them trailers dropped
and it has you know what you call
locking whatever the conquering hero
right a different film it was a
different energy
the world does stop with these games and
a trail so all it takes like i said i
know people
like to have fun with the correct beams
and that's cute but when games
drop and you see it actually
tangible it's a different energy that's
all i'm saying yeah again i'm not
guaranteeing these games are going to be
great provided there's no master chief
collection type situations
all i'm saying is we got to do that and
the last part i'm saying this is the
king's point and i'll finish up
which is the reason why i'm not
stressing with all of this oh
you know this is a messed up if it's not
here and there's no first party games
and i gotta wait
see the difference with the xbox
ecosystem that i appreciate
like king said is game pass you know
what i'm saying because at the end of
the day
when you have an outriders and mlb the
show
that's a a third-party game right
that makes their ecosystem feel like
that's the place where you're supposed
to play
because i don't feel like i feel like
i'm getting away with somebody right
i feel like yo how about playing this
like so the beauty of it of game pass is
when you
have a drought so to speak you could
potentially go to e and say hey
battlefield six man there we go we could
drop it i didn't
even that like i was i was trying to
explain to somebody i was arguing on
twitter as i normally do
so um you know that's my that's my side
job at this point
but um we were having a discussion about
they were saying like oh well
xbox hasn't had a game in 600 days and
i'm like it doesn't feel
like that though like it doesn't just
simply because with game pass
it's like in terms of the big
aaa exclusives like it doesn't feel like
it doesn't feel like we haven't had
anything
but exactly like [ __ ] again i can't
speak at all
but on game my backlog is lit
like i got tons of stuff to play you
don't say so again
i get it it just dropped dodgeball yeah
what's
that in the
my son ran downstairs leaped in front of
my tv
i said daddy did you try to knock out
the dodgeball game
right i said yeah they dropped it in
game pass i downloaded it
and he said it's amazing and ran back
upstairs
so who who who's who are these people
that says
xbox has nothing right or there's no
games in there
those are individuals that have not been
able to maintain a subscription service
right
so those individuals on my timeline i
don't listen to
i don't hear it i can't hear it i'm tone
deaf to your
ability to say that this content here
that i won't partake in and i will
continue to say that there's no content
there
right you have a visualization problem
all you have to do is open your eyes
right and open your wallet and you have
access to this this is not closed off to
me
in a segment of the community right i
told people on my playstation it doesn't
start
until well ratchet and clank hit when
ratchet clank hit that's when that
generation starts for me
and i'm over there but again i don't
ever run around saying playstation
doesn't have
games right because there's obviously
there's people playing games over there
obviously it's people enjoying stuff
over there so that narrative that we
need a one-two punch right
we don't but when it comes to because
the game pass like
my brother's playing that snow trucker
game like
yeah yeah it's just like at the end of
the taste anyway
yeah but at the end of the day like
people got to stop with this mentality
if i don't like it it doesn't matter
yeah because it's their world like if
they if it's not hot to them
then it can't it can't be hot to
millions of other people
you don't say i cut it they're like
no continue yeah i was just cutting
because it was a lot oh i i was
listening
at the end of the day people it's gonna
be fine like
even if this year does become a little
bit lackluster
you know just halo like like let's stop
acting like we don't have all these
third parties dropping this holiday if
you don't like halo
like chances are you're probably playing
card or 2k anyway
like like all these other games coming
out like i've always suggested like
ratchet and clank comes out next month
why aren't you playing that
like there's plenty to play out there
just get out of your your comfort zone
and play more than three games a year
but what it is maddie
the thing is what that's the last point
i don't know
you know the thing is they're like oh
you guys are making excuses for xbox
you know matty you're making it you you
hyped
up too much and now you got to be held
accountable
like how do you feel about like so
you're not allowed maddie to be excited
at all dude for the potential people
people conflate
if this is this even happens i hate to
say it like in
higher up people in our industry i'll
just say oftentimes conflate
people talking just discussing with
excitement
so yeah like i said i don't need to name
names but like people were just like oh
my god stop
hyping up starfield you know these these
rumors and then they drop a rumor and
i'm like dude what are you doing like
come on man this happens way too often
it's like people are going to talk
people want to talk about this thing
they're interested because
the people who are higher up in the
industry who direct the conversation
oftentimes
are communicating about it so you know
i get it's from time to time not too
often but i'll sit there
i'm invested in what i talk about right
like because once again we talked about
at the start of this like once if
once you start faking it people know so
yeah when i'm talking you got 100 of my
attention
and and my energy and so some people are
like man why
starfield in particular in this case
like matt why is maddie so excited about
star field we don't know i don't know
anything about this game it's like you
are
clearly confusing me just wanting to
have a talk about this game which is
relevant to my interest but also
to my channel and everything right
you're confusing that with just
excitement like if i'm off the walls
like we're talking fallout 4
yeah go look at my trailer reaction dude
i'm literally like in this spot here in
this corner like bouncing
i'm off the walls like that's excitement
that's excitement man but like when
we're sitting here just engaged and
having a chat like that's not excitement
man like
when the conversation starts we want to
finish it and that's yes that's the
energy that people should carry is
because often times
what's crazy i was gonna say was crazies
it comes from the same people that hype
up e3 every year right
we're literally guilty guilty
same people that tell you not to hype
stuff it's like we're literally hyped
for an event that's going to tell us
games coming out years from 10 things
that might be at e3 it's like
don't be excited why are people
mad at other people's excitement
if we could get real philosophical let's
get let's get real with it right like
why are you mad that someone is
possibly excited for it like i don't get
that i got a lot of hate for super lucky
too
yeah like it's just weird energy like
this stuff i don't care about right
but it's like yo i know king like that
joint you know what i'm saying
i can see like i'm not the biggest fable
guy right but i see what addict is like
yo
you know what i'm saying it's just i
don't understand this weird energy
that you know some in the community have
that you're not allowed to be
hyped about you don't know what it is
you can't be hyperbolic right you can't
you can't be high by the idea of it you
can't wait
let's be real here it's it's it's
because it's an exclusive it doesn't
happen if it's
are you implying oh no they was happy as
well i thought it was going to go
out are you implying that before
i don't did you i have do you remember
what do you remember no i don't oh
before
okay when they was clowning and
everything talking about all the other
dates y'all paid all that money and
those games are going to be
everything yeah i remember distinctly
people on my timeline on your timeline
on
iop timeline yes talking about when it
does come out
and it comes off everything
he called it the five stages of grief he
was just like acceptance
it's denial first yeah at the end
at the end of the day when the last time
you know there's exception third-party
games
the stuff that has that has literally
evolved beyond gaming like call of duty
obviously you have the call of duty
haters
but what's the last time you sat someone
i don't care about
basketball baseball what have you ever
seen me on my time like
why are you why are you looking forward
to madden why are you looking forward to
2k
i don't care like that's that's your bag
play it
i don't even attack cod fans like
the showcase it's just weird energy
as game is we got to do better you know
i'm moving forward we just got to do
better
allow people to be happy if they're
happy about something if you don't care
about it
you ain't got to voice your displeasure
with someone's excitement
like keep it to yourself like no one
cares about it it's just weird
to me because if somebody likes
something i don't like yo god bless you
that's your thing
i feel you you're getting that banger
that you want
salute you you know what i'm saying kind
of thing but let's move on um do you
want to merge that topic in
yeah so i was going to say my topic
really was like i do
feel like to a degree it is a little bit
of these people making these games
issues like i feel like sometimes they
be releasing announcing games like
way too soon like like sometimes
people will announce games and the thing
gets cancelled
like like if you're announcing games
that
short in development that it gets
cancelled before it ends development
then maybe you should have waited on
that like like
example you know i can understand
certain games like the last of us two
nine times that ten that's coming out we
have
a good understanding what that kind of
game's gonna be but starfield was
announced like four years
ago it feels like like so we've been
doing nothing but talking about it for
four years
elder scrolls was announced four years
ago it's a little bit different because
it's
it's elder scrolls we kind of know the
universe we know the franchise it's okay
but what do you guys think do you think
that maybe the industry as a whole
should
like reflect on what's going on with our
game that's announced too soon
maddie yeah i go back and forth on it
because
i am really a strong believer in like
information
and i think it's good to know you know
what's coming what's in your pipeline my
problem really stands with just
like how few people are allowed to bring
information to the table
um you know i've said this pretty openly
like you know it's it's typically
through jason schreier jeff grubb like
very minimal outlets outside of that
you'll see time and time out there will
be an occasional
different name pop up um but i think
it's
you know it's super important that we
know what's coming up but on the other
hand yeah it's
you can't control people's expectations
and their excitement you can only do
your job as my mindset so it's like yeah
i'm gonna bring you this starfield
information we don't know if it's gonna
be good or bad but
you're not gonna blame me for you
getting yourself hyped like yeah at that
point i got to tell you i got to hit you
with the spaghettio's energy
come on man
so yeah there are some cases i it is
case by case that's kind of the
problem you know what it's equivalent to
maddie it's people blaming pre-orders on
broken games
it's like you can't blame the consumer
for going out and supporting the
franchise or the
the game they're hyped for we should aim
that towards the people releasing broken
games
yeah man
what happens is a lot of this discourse
occurs on twitter where there's not
enough room for nuance right so we can
sit here and parse through things and
talk about like well in the case of
scale bound
that was way too early but in the case
of cyberpunk i feel like they were
transparent but
turns out it was kind of cloak and
dagger move and yeah you see you have
all these different situations where
like for us to develop the conversation
it needs to go beyond
just people firing off on social media
right um
and it's also once again just that pure
responsibility
that people need to have for themselves
like not like if jeff grubb
when he told me hey not me sorry uh when
he when he reported like oh mass effect
trilogy remaster is a thing
yeah it's happening when he says that
like that's all there is to it it's not
his fault if people get really hyped at
that like it's an exciting premise on
paper just like star field is it's a new
ip from
bethesda's a team like yeah give me that
like that's exciting but you know
you can't be excited about the product
at that point so yeah to an extent i
think the industry pulls the trigger a
little too early
i have to say though i think xbox is the
biggest offender of that i
i really do man they i i really really
do
um because these games are far out and
they're just like let's
let's announce fable it's like you know
attic i get it man i know like you
got to be on like that you got to be on
like the double side too because it's
like
we can't ask them what the what what the
road map is
and then they tell us the road map he's
like you now see's too soon because
we demanded them to tell us these games
yeah yeah man
so that's what it just goes it goes back
and forth like
i wan on one instance like yeah please
like hold your announcements but i also
want to know i i'm a believer that if
you could show me gameplay then it's
time to show it right like
yeah i don't think it's going to
dramatically shift that much if a
gameplay trailer can be ready
which is why i'm wondering what they're
going to do with starfield right like we
get this like title reveal
trailer so i'm i'm thinking xbox loves
their cgi's like are we gonna see
starfield in
action there's like a couple to a little
extent so i don't know i'm expecting
more shrunken down thing with like
a bigger reveal maybe later in the year
like a quake con or something okay so
okay maddie i'm gonna break it down just
a little bit more let's go
if you were the one that's like the pr
came to like maddie
how we gonna announce this game what
kind of time duration would you
show any type of trailer before anything
like to me i feel like a cgi is okay if
it's just announcing the game
but if once you announce the game with
that initial cgi
i don't want to see your stuff until
it's gameplay ready at all
how would you feel like that would be
the best way to go
i would disagree i would rather just
like
like i want to make a game right like i
truly do
nice for me when i reveal that i'm going
to show you
in action like i don't want to give you
an idea i want you to see the thing
and no it must have i'm gonna sound like
a little bit like todd howard it would
be real but like
i
because i just love the idea of hey
here's this thing here's what it looks
like here's how it plays and and here's
when you're getting it like we know like
does it just work matty does it just
i hope it does and but you know that's
a while from now but like when the time
comes like yeah i want to keep that
short like i want to keep it long enough
where people can hear about it and learn
about it i don't want to have
i think hades plays hades played a
dangerous game is an example i think of
where they did this early access over on
epic
and if it wasn't for word of mouth man
like that game i don't know how it would
have done but like more and more people
kept saying like
this is good yeah and i'm on the same
boat like
i bought it through word of mouth not
every game is blessed that way so you
need some time to just get the name
out there and so like yeah for me it's
like as a smaller games like let's keep
it to three four months
but in in the window of triple a it's
like keep it to half a year keep it
like yeah about it like because that
window if it's tight man like and your
game is good it does
well because people it's just there's a
short containment period of
here's the game name here's what it
looks like here the beats are going to
hit here's the marketing we're going to
do
right and then you're there at lunch man
it's like there's no letting off the gas
it's not like what ubisoft used to do
which is like
a year and a half i think that might
that kind of timeline might be a little
bit different for console
manufacturers though because like they
kind of do have to show
what's in line in their line to sell a
platform
like that's why playstation at the
beginning of generations
they just shoot what's coming out five
years from now because
they want yo last of us two's coming out
we don't know when
but it's coming out like i think that
changes now
i think um and to matty's point
i understand like the cadence that you
uh
presented that's a cadence that
microsoft will be comfortable with
once these uh developers are
churning out the games in that that time
frame
because then you want to give a road map
to your game pass platform
you want to give a road map to stuff
that's coming out so it gives you a
thought process of
on how they're releasing when they're
releasing double a triple a i don't like
to give a's
and stuff like that but um to to these
titles that come out because ascent
might be my aaa title of the year i
don't know
until i get it and and i explore it and
i play the game
but again we're going to get to that
space
and and i believe microsoft will be the
masters of that space
due to uh the uh amount of studios that
they do
have and the the the internal take
on how they're viewing their
infrastructure at xbox
they're viewing the infrastructure xbox
through a prism of game pass
in doing so you are changing
how the landscape goes for gaming as a
whole
in that xbox brand right and
you want to extend it to a state that
these
companies your developers are producing
content
in a span that keeps it churning keeps
it going it's a machine
that keeps going so i understand what
you're saying you know from your aspect
i think it's going to change yeah
because we're dealing with the old model
and we're converting to the new model
and i think we're going to get past that
too far out announcement
but for attic attic needed to hear
fable was in production attic needed
that because
i legitly i was with him convinced it
wasn't it wasn't yeah
and you know and they were listening to
you they they heard your pain i was
sitting right next to you i felt so bad
for him
i swear to god you know when it wasn't
shown and and
the curtain goes up and we was like damn
man i think what makes it worse for
people like us is we know a little bit
that's behind the scenes so yeah yeah
like we expect it and we don't see it we
get to support that because we know it's
there yeah
we we a lot of the hardcore gaming
community has their
you know ear really to the ground and
then
when those rumors don't turn out to
happen at e3
then all of a sudden to them is a major
point but i want to get before i go and
i want to get into anchor
and get like yo you know are games
announced too soon for you
what's the right way to do it i see you
chimed in on what maddie said
uh for me like i i always viewed like
fallout 4 as like the perfect
media grouping where it was they
announced it
less than a month later they showed it
showed game play
gave us a deep dive here's the release
date and then after that like they had
very short
trailers i always loved bethesda's
live-action trailers that they put
together
um i just i always loved that because
they they do it at a weird frame rate
where it looks like
it could be really good gameplay
uh but i always love those trailers but
for me like i like the whole
six months to nine months just depending
on how what kind of game it is
um if they could do six to nine months
that would be
great uh because we give people just
enough time all right
i think what king was talking about
earlier you got to think about in terms
of game pass in terms
of all right how do you have these
announcements in a time frame
where you can keep people subscribed to
it just long enough
right where they don't cancel the
subscription the reason described later
no good point i think six to nine months
is that a kind of questionable period
like yeah i might i might not if there's
another game i might like or not just it
just depends
i think any longer than that though you
can have that whole group of people who
just migrate whenever it's available
yep shout out to the cops going by i was
trying to talk with the cops yeah look
man i'll make a quick um good question
i think god dang cops
they look at the end of the day it's a
good question
i can i'm with you maddie i can see both
sides to it
and it's like you want to generate hype
definitely for your game
and i think there is a value to it you
know
for showing hope for the future right
yeah they working on this they're doing
this right
but then to your point you also want to
set
the anxiety you want to set realistic
expectation right because at the end of
the day i i agree with what i got like i
like how bethesda does it in the sense
that
like when they finally do show there's
that
that window where you know it's most
likely coming it's ready you know it's
ready to get out they're doing stuff
like that
and i i like that and with starfish
because we're using a starfield the
example
there's a part of me that i don't know
if king will relate like i miss the
secrecy of not doing it's part of me
that likes the secrecy of not knowing
totally what it is you know it's over
what happened we are behind the curtain
i know
the emperor has no clothes who the
wizard truly is
you know for us it's spoiled for us the
layman dudes that's out there and the
speculation and the love they see i i go
i live through their eyes
in their hopes sometimes i don't want to
hear anything sometimes i don't play
demos sometimes
i stay away from certain you stay away
from it i know yeah i try my
best you want it to be brand new once
you get it you don't want to hear it i
know i get it and that part
it like i said that's why i'm conflicted
because there's a part of me that i
even though sometimes we clown them like
yo it's just a jpeg they
ain't saying they show no we don't know
what it is there's a part of me
that get that i like that gives hope
like let's be real when nintendo does
that metroid i seen the nintendo
fan base and i see nintendo new york go
crazy
nintendo new york and i was so happy for
them because they just wanted to know
it was coming you know what i'm saying i
yeah all right
no no come on go maddie i see you i see
you i was just gonna say i i think it
just
now that we've talked about more i think
what i've felt is like if you know the
thing like like with addict and
fable or or new york with uh with with
metroid it's like you know it and
so in the case of fable we'll say like
okay we know it's playground we know
their history with with open world
racism literally just waiting for the
announcement yeah
exactly like confirming that and knowing
like fable is a thing you have a history
there like what is gonna change like
there's an expectation you sort of
know about it something like starfield i
think they did
pull the trigger on too early just
just because i i wouldn't say that
because i think we'd be in a darker spot
but
that's what i'm saying there's so much
to this but imagine a thing a game like
star field
where we don't know what it is it is a
new ip yes
it's like all right what do we expect i
don't know and so you just wonder for in
this case now it's
it's going to be three years in june and
no
thought process let me just finish this
last part i get to go at it i just did
i understand both sides to it i
understand where you're going matt you
got to say what king's going like yo
don't show me nothing
until it's ready i'm saying i don't want
to see a jpeg i don't and king is even
worse to me he don't even want to see a
vertical slice
i'm with you maddie don't make
i'll gameplay i give him credit he's
been on his square
with that like i get excited sometimes
by a vertical strike he's like nah
i want to see the game i don't know i've
been fooled too long man yeah he'd be
like no
because we come for the ever before but
you know the other final fantasy
that i want to say though there is a
part of me
that when there's a game i had no
knowledge of right
and then they stat studio shows the game
right or maybe i just heard that they
may have been working on something
and like the game play or the trick
really impresses me
sometimes that does get me hyped like yo
i wasn't paying this no mom but now that
i've seen it
like yo this is i want to know what's
going on i'm in you know what i'm saying
there's certain
you don't say indie games and
third-party games that come into that
thing but
last point i'll say is that you know set
realistic expectations
be transparent and if you need more time
delay
delay delay that's the great job that's
right anyone else else
yeah let me do my actual topic real
quick
look this is this is how i want it okay
i
in my realistic thing i'd like to stuff
bethesda does
but i think as a platform holder i don't
think that's a realistic thing that they
can do for the most part
like they got to show some kind of you
know future for the
for their platform they've always done
that i don't see that changing
um i don't really like
i like the the we're going to announce
stuff
this e3 for next year we're going to
announce stuff next e3 for the year
after that
like i think that's a decent middle
ground i don't think people should be
announcing games that's two or three
years in advance they won't have
this this e3 i would prefer
to see stuff that's only coming out next
e3 like the
duration between here and next e3 right
but i know
as a platform holder that's something
that they can't do realistically with
the majority of their games
like they have investors that they want
to hype up they want to show all this
interest in these things like it's not a
realistic thing
if i had it my way everyone in the
industry would be doing it to bethesda
way
six months your game's out but i just
don't think that's a realistic thing
or more specifically like you're talking
about attic um
like one of the things i was worried
about when they showed starfield and
the elder scrolls trailer like that i
was like why are they showing this so
early this is not
bethesda mo this is kind of like like
they're showing this way too
early and now like yeah they were trying
to be sold
they were selling imagine
well not just that but think about
warner brothers they went for sale
earlier and then they said now we're
going off the market
they showed um gotham knights and then
they showed
uh suicide squad and now they're
supposedly back on the market again
but after showing that and that kind of
increases their value again
right but that's a point of like why
do they show it so early as well you
know what would be crazy though is if
if bethesda kept their their standpoint
on stuff and didn't show starfield
and elder scrolls we knew that our
scrolls would come out but not star
filled
and then they get bought by microsoft
and microsoft reveal starfish
that would have been applied to us yeah
that would have been applied just but
look
that's what i got let's go on long joint
um let's do
this quick looking this is uh something
you want to talk about in our final time
i got no remarks on that
oh my lord and uh yeah the news
regarding uh
bio mutant and um shout out to uh thq
doing it you know they are put out a
statement in reference to it and it
looks like obviously it's been developed
for a pastor
why is king flexing this all developed
for pastor
i can't look at you right now oh so
basically you know
obviously it works on playstation 5 and
xbox series x due to
backward compatibility but um looks like
at launch they did make a statement
in stating that the native resolution
for the ps5 will be played at 1080p
upscale
to 4k due to some stability and
performance issues
that will now be resolved by the game's
debut and that's being set for
uh may 25th and the other comment i want
to talk about
is uh actually their twitter account for
buyer mutant and um they pretty much
said hey we promised the footage
we put it out and then people were
asking okay why is that the case
you know as far as the resolution thing
or whatever and the hq
nordic says due to technical reasons
we've deactivated
native 4k on playstation 5 for the
release version of the game
by mutant is currently running against
dictators he's smiling way too much he's
probably too much but look this is
king's topic
he couldn't wait to talk about this in
the round so lord king
your thoughts on bio mutant tcl
stand up oh my god do you see your
television gang
if you have a tcl television and a
playstation 5 we got a game for you
oh my god and
listen keep the same energy it's just
like maternal
you 1080p dudes you thought it was the
next generation
it's not for you
no variable reshaping rate none of that
he can't even say it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i knew i knew for a fact you guys was in
trouble
i knew it i knew i knew he was in
trouble with
this is the second what do you call that
call oh no this is actually the third
time
uh yes early earlier this month uh this
is actually something that popped up too
i found that this morning i didn't even
realize it uh sniper ghost warrior they
have their
contracts too yeah yeah they announced
back on the seventh
that they were also having problems with
the playstation 5 version so they
uh not canceled they've delayed that
indefinitely another one
same exact thing
what do you call the playstation it's a
is it an unstable situation it's an
unstable juggling console
okay listen so i told y'all when i was
listening
i was like look at this deep dive into
the playstation so you need to
you need to check it out so when
markzware was talking about oh
juggling and he was talking about well
you know if the
cons if the game needs power then the
power will be
transformed and the gpu will know when
to act
now
then the cpu will take over
i said that's that sounds like a mess it
sounds like a problem
so nothing you can count on nobody here
at no point in time
and it's showing itself so when they say
we want 60 frames per second they say
well
you got to look through it through some
shades
you and ray right now i don't have uh
the 4k visuals right now cause i got no
shades
when i take it off i feel like xbox
right
right now i'm doing a playstation so
1080p is happening and you guys can't do
nothing about it
the console is weak and and i'm so happy
why are you have you voted because i
knew i told you
or see we talked about it earlier i said
i was going to get resident evil
yes and i said no i wanted
bio mutant because i waited for it so
long and i knew that game was going to
be fantastic and there's a small
development team that's making it
and i just really want to play that game
because it interests me on so many
different levels it looks like breath
for the wild
with rpg elements to different aspects
and the little creatures look so
fantastic the world interests me so much
and i haven't been interested in a world
like that
in such a long time that this is where
my dollars is going
and i've i've been vocal about it and
then come to find out this is the gift
that
keeps on giving like
so if you want to compete like
this is the problem that you guys should
really have and you should guys should
take the twitter
and you should avoid your disappointment
at sony mm-hmm
oh we gotta go to sodium yeah you told
me to demand better from microsoft and
jason ronald and the team has delivered
okay they have delivered my xbox series
x will be playing at 4k
60 and i will be having a great time
in the beginning of the generation the
playstation 5 what happened now
resolution advantages what happened now
when jason sat down
and started and they started taking the
dev kits and twisting the boats and
fixing it
i told y'all before we were doing it off
the verb
we went to the basketball court we
didn't work out we didn't put in no work
no pre-workout no nothing
and we was hanging with you i said what
happens
when we take it seriously we take the
pre-workout
and we start doing our push-ups every
day now what
what happens now now you see who's doing
1080p
60 and who's doing 4k
60. so at this point in time are we
gonna start acknowledging the elephant
in the room
i gotta say because there is some
important stuff about this too because
i've been following biomedia for years
um i specifically waited before
pre-ordering it all because
i'm also just worried everything's going
to end up on game pass i just wanted to
two weeks before yeah
i went about two weeks before and i'm
like all right they didn't announce
anything
it's probably not going to be on game
pass i'll jump in now
um they did not get access to next-gen
consoles until like recently
right right and so for them this
particular game
is not the next the modes are gonna be
available at the start
are not the next gen versions of this
game these are the
last gen versions and really what you're
seeing here is
microsoft dominating with backwards
compatibility and just being able to
smart even those
in the squad
this is the foresight that microsoft
jason ronald and the team mm-hmm with
the back compat and to the great bill
still will oh yes
the legend do you know how good it feels
maddie
to go to the restaurant of your choice
and the filet mignon
is brought out to you and
and the beautiful wine kevin is
and then you look over at the other
restaurant
and they're selling burgers
they're eating burgers and fries
this is getting out of hand walks up as
a sommelier with a wine list
they come to your table and they slice
your meat for you
on a rotisserie and everything is white
gloves
and over here
you guys got to choose like you got to
choose if you want intelligence
or if you want to work out because you
can be real strong and dumb
real smart and weak
over here we balance we do full body
workouts
we're intelligent too weights and we're
doing calculus
so are you saying playstation's skipping
too many leg days oh man
they come in these legs are spaghetti
legs
we have over here he go out of control
this is what happens king does this and
then we get accused
of being oh you guys the whole battle
these are kings
remember that but look let's finish up
lord maddie buy your mute
anchor by a mutant lord addict real
quickly what do you guys thought about
this whole thing were you interested by
me and lord badly start with you first
so i'm reviewing it uh so i can only say
i can't talk to the to the
the quality of the game really i i like
i gotta do a careful dance earlier i'm
sorry
you don't have to you don't have to you
have to just wait what sucks is you
gotta wait one day right like tomorrow
it goes out
so it's like oh man but anyway um yeah
from the outside looking i made a video
about this game because it's this
post-apocalyptic
kung fu open world rpg seems to be
taking choice a little seriously i'm
like
dang and then you look it's like a
20-man team
all right still asking for 60 bucks but
all things accounted for it looks like a
lot of new ideas so for me
i was very interested on this and i do
crack one joke about the uh the quality
of the game in terms of uh visual
fidelity
in my review so yeah so just on that
topic well but
i i was very curious about this one i've
i've finally answered my curiosity i am
looking forward to talking about it a
lot more because what i'm excited to see
is a lot of people have signed on to
this game
i thought it was going to continue to be
under the radar title i was like
it's starting to smell a little bit like
it had that game pass stink on it it's
like
man you're going to need that market and
energy just a little bit right i was
like i smell something
and so i was thinking that that was
heading that path i'm
that's one thing that's great about this
year we started talking about like
earlier on hey
you know this might be a little bit of a
vacant year but what's happening is
people are discovering new things
like biomutant is a game that i think
typically wouldn't get this mass
attention especially with
in the discussion of visual fidelity man
but like it is now and and it's an
important launch for people
because they're picking and choosing
like may was the busiest month we had we
had what mass effect resident evil
fraternal and
huge but like when you look at other
years we had that
like three months in a row there would
be like big game big game man all that
happened this month the return of came
out
not even a month ago man i know right
like i played maternal
three months ago i know i know and
so i'm you know i'm excited because
people are looking into this new style
rpg i am admittedly a little
surprised people are big on it because
you know
i looked at it and thought to myself
well
it's a 20-man team and they're doing a
lot of things to me that's that's always
a
a not a red flag but it's like okay they
either nail this
or they're being spread thin and we'll
see how it plays out right so
it is a game that my review aside i
would have said i'm
looking out for a wait for review and
just seeing what people think because it
is a thq nordic game they do very
interesting stuff
they publish some pretty solid titles
like you look at darksiders threes one i
wasn't big on that game
i had a lot of cool ideas and i hope
they do more from that franchise but i
gave it away for a sale
they did kingdoms with ammo or
re-reckoning i covered that a ton
and like the fact that they even got
that game out again is i i say always
like i wasn't big on it as a remaster
but as a video game please play it but
the fact that they got that thing out is
give them a crown man that's crazy that
that
that thing got pulled out of the corpse
of ea and and kurt schilling and it's
like why
oh yeah yeah like like in 38 studios or
big 38 like dude we just talked about it
i love jason about that whole history in
his book
i didn't know any of that stuff yeah the
lawsuits with
uh with rhode island i mean
they they pulled it out so it's cool
they do it i'm glad people are willing
to support them so i'm gonna be curious
to see
i've been talking to some people i'm
gonna be curious to see what folks think
of the discourse over bio mutant
i'll say that fair enough can't wait for
you to break that defensive edition xbox
[Laughter]
announced bio mutant years ago i mean uh
was an alcoholic holocaust or drunk cat
on twitter
we were just hyping that game up and
then it was like yeah this game's not
coming out for a while
so we just had to play all right we're
gonna come back to this later and then
we put it like put
the hype back up again so i've been
excited for it i think
i think a lot of the new hype yes is
because it's been kind of
sparse lately and so like any game that
comes out it's gonna get attention you
know like back in 2014 it was basically
like yep everyone gave attention to mad
max all of a sudden
just like you know shadow of mordor
games we would normally wouldn't pay
that much attention to got that kind of
because it's kind of
a slow pace again coving and all this
stuff going on absolutely yeah i agree
yeah a little bit of that time to watch
your game believe it or not yeah
absolutely
absolutely yeah perfect time yeah but
the other thing too
and this is going to sound really weird
um a lot of the people and this is just
just me my personal experience talking
to people they're excited about it
because of ghost of tsushima
because it's they well what they've been
seeing is that that mercenary class with
the hat and everything and they're
thinking oh wait this is
this kind of reminds me of that a little
bit some reason excited
no xbox sleep loudly enough they hoping
for a patch
they said they said they will release
the patch later
little things that people have just been
kind of pulling stuff into this
game from things that are completely
unrelated to it
as a reason to be excited for it right
and also i mean hey i
i always like when a small team works on
something i love the double
a space personally i normally find with
the double a space people are more
willing to try riskier things yes
it's boring it's like either gotta have
something that looks amazing
or you know his it's something cool and
so i'm excited for them
i want to see what they're gonna do i
like the fact they've been transparent
about all this
like they said hey we just got next-gen
systems like two weeks ago
playstation for having tired back
capacitors
when playstation said we don't believe
in back compact
now you know why
i think we have fed uh king's ego a
little bit too much today so
this has nothing to do with me i i'm
going i'm going to
pass my and in my topic i'm just
i'm not feeding that anymore it's it's
gotten too bulgy on it man
wait what jason's right like what do you
call him the rank and final kick
yes the rank and foul
i want everyone in the air shot of my
voice
to go out and purchase the definitive
edition
oh now
regardless before the the the
conversation came out with the
resolution and stuff like that
i've always been intrigued by that game
the game has shown me a level of
excellence
from the small development team that
that demands my dollar
right and then to see the game and it's
not a cut scene because a lot of times
like what you're saying is vertical
slices and stuff like that
so maddie when you saw the game and he
was like and i know you questioned it at
first is that a vertical slice
is this and then you saw it was actual
gameplay with it
that that definitely it has something to
it and i've had not heard
anything bad from anyone about this game
so they were going to get my dollars
when i said it's the gift that keeps on
giving to be fair lord maddie just said
he's under an embargo
that's probably not about he can't say
he can't say anything right my smile is
my smile
exactly and it speaks volumes
no no it's just it's just i'm not gonna
allow these dudes
because us xbox dudes and i want you to
put your bayonets up oh god
because when that little s is doing
1440p
at 30 frames per second flexing its
little muscles
and i'm telling you you got to ask
yourself this question is the
playstation 5 holding this generation
it's this inferior console holding
us back from greater pastures where it
can't even achieve
1440p and don't you tell me that the s
is the weaker console
when it's out working you in the gym
so you've been holding on to this okay i
definitely have
and i'm gonna tell you right now i want
y'all to put your bayonets up
so this is the part where if you just
gotta ask me it was like i wasn't able
to get an x
you got a stronger console in the
playlist so now because of the tv
that's right you know what 120 frames
means a lot when you don't have a dc
i just want to point out this is bio
mute and he's referring yeah yeah he's
clearly capitalized
like some giant third party
you know listen listen listen you got to
take your roses when you can't i feel
that
and this is the part of the story where
i say
it sucks to be you guys oh
[Laughter]
thank y'all for sticking with us i had
to bring the smoke for
all you guys that stuck around
527 people i hope i delivered
what you was waiting for absolutely
absolutely yeah this was worth the wait
you're going to get back i'm not going
to
salute the maddie for for dealing with
our foolishness oh deal with come on man
we go long but you know look i'm with
king say i mean we're not with king or
that he's with me
i'm sorry not with that [ __ ] got him
as far as the funniest with his time
he's been labeled
it's over he provided the entertainment
the realm needed
as far as the situation i don't know
what's going on if it's the back compat
thing it proves to be
i i i don't care about why i want to be
honest it's not something i was checking
for but no disrespect to anybody who is
because i don't kill excitement
i don't care thank you thank you are you
excited
i'm excited for you brother you know so
that's why man and you know we'll see
what happens if they you know if for
technical reasons or they come out with
a patch if not whatever it
you know it is what it is they better
come out with a passion i've done if you
want the definitive version
listen to king and go get you a serious
action
but anyway let's get the poll and truly
get out of here
and let's get the super chat real quick
but let me you want to get the super
chats down there yeah there's not many
afternoon lords really enjoyed maddie's
content glad to see him
hear mass effect 2 over mass effect 1 oh
we gotta find out super chat from dan
lorenzo can playstation really afford to
release god of war as a playstation 5
only exclusive with
so few systems in the market time
between releases
is necessary uh warlord 101.5
five dollar super chat we have to we
have to be honest
as a community about the hype train
created by youtubers
about starfield now everyone is clean up
duty
it's disappointing we got a two super
chat from raiden blade hello fellas i'm
listening from work
we got a five dollar stream from warlord
nobody said nah
i hope starfield slips 2022 a month ago
the problem is nobody wants to record
to be on record as being wrong about it
that's not helpful go
jets okay yes i'm a jeff fan
five super chat from raiden blade hey
king thanks for the uh thanks for
playing outrights with
me the other day oh yeah i listen i tell
guys all the time
you know
[Music]
you got maddie played love your content
you got a five super chat from raiden
played
the problem is no one gives a release
date so why on earth would
anyone be saying starfield is delayed we
gotta
to the super chat from raiden blade when
addicts said i'm happy
uh now for fable reveal okay
so uh then we got a five dollar
superchat from underground gamer
sorry bros hyped my uh star filled until
microsoft
took their lunch money now xbox fans are
over hyping get that fraud alert
jesus should you say
oh the sage we know full world this boy
if this by a mutant see what i did there
my immune okay i got it situation was
reversing xbox
oh my god xbox would be getting hammered
variable
uh resolution right on ps5 we got a two
dollar super chat from
uh duvi hi uh uh hashtag book of x
and we got one we got a two super chat
from mass
uh massarex uh he's back
there he is there it is
and then we got oh my okay we got a five
dollar shot from gaming forte
king must be part of that spec op groups
oh he's definitely special let's see
right now and i love
keep being real and entertaining and we
got a ten dollar super chat from jd
gamer
just dropping support to the realm i
appreciate it
danger gamers one of the og og shout out
to suicide king fight i was put in my
five dollars and passes the
the plate to my right great stuff you
found the collection to play all right
salute back for dead i see you yeah
we're going into uh vaulted glass right
now the podcast let's do the poll get
out of here
new lognet iop poll it's up on
launchinggaming.net
right now so go check that out um if the
rumors
regarding starfield's release date are
true and it falls to late
2022 which xbox game
are you most excited for by microsoft in
2021
the choices are a rumored forza horizon
in new mexico
b unannounced xbox game at
e3 c halo infinite
or d i don't care i'm just tired of halo
gears of force
that is the question those are the
choices please rock the vote when it
goes up on iop lordsgaming.net twitter
the legendary lord maddie
plays rocked out with us for damn near
four hours
and i am so thankful tremendous content
creator
love what he does in the community
actually right like a highly requested
guest
oh one of the highest people were like
you got to do something with matty you
got to do something i said
that's really nice you're trying and i'm
very thankful
that you reached out you know salute to
acg as well
i love what you guys do but to you as
well you know
just what you bring to community i love
the originality i love the passion
you know and you see your growth you
know tell the found people where they
can find you
what else you got going on so this
coming week is i call them 2.0 weeks
i didn't say this at the top but like i
i did like a a relaunch on my channel
called mr maddie place 2.0 so the idea
is is pretty much like
a push for originality in a derivative
space where we're still going to do news
and stuff like you you'll see that
reviews like
stuff that i've always done that'll be
priority number one but i'm starting to
push these more original ideas so this
week we're going back to jade empire in
the time machine uh we're gonna be
dumping into batman dark tomorrow i hope
none of y'all played that game but
that's for uh ximena's worst game always
are you bad at his worst
yeah yeah so gotta get back into that
and that's gonna be torturous i bought a
batman costume for it so that's fun
so yeah i'm diving into that and we're
working on a dark age of bethesda video
kind of highlighting that time period
where they were like just putting out
like rogue warrior like this
real just what is happening man like uh
so manchester united
[Laughter]
instantly his cheeks got red this is why
[Laughter]
so yeah we're working on all of that
plus the podcast i do
so you can find me over on youtube mr
maddie plays that's where i'm streaming
i'm doing my daily content
um and so we're pretty interactive over
there
if you want to personally interact with
me over on twitter it's at g27 status
that's my actually second youtube
channel name so i keep it remember your
roots you know
all right so that's there where you can
interact with me every time i try to tag
you in something that always yeah
it throws me that's why that's why i
changed my name to mr maddie play so
when you type in mr maddie you'll see
that
pop up yeah yeah so you can go ahead and
find me there
uh instagram if you want i barely post
because i don't really take photos i'm a
living the moment kind of guy but mr
maddie plays underscore official if you
want to check me out there
otherwise defining duke over on last
damn media ham radio on my own channel
and check me out oh and patreon.com mr
maddie plays but please watch some of my
content first before you decide to to
pay anything like that that's
important but you know in case you want
to know it's there as well no doubt
salute to you brother
again love what you do in the community
tremendous content
oh what's up give me 13 seconds i've
missed one super chat
we got a two a super chat from raiden
blade king has a point ps5 is holding us
back oh my god
oh no oh and there we go
massive we got yeah you get that one
yeah shout out
to him um don't forget to check out
foxreal yes fatherly gaming is live
right now go check it out if you guys
are chilling on sunday
and um yeah again but again maddie like
looking forward to to what else you do
in the future and i just love to see the
ascension you've been putting it in for
a long time
keep it fantastic and hopefully we will
get you back in the realm
i am more than open man you let me know
when i'm happy
facts love to work with you again
brother and of course the legend the iop
og the believer in the movement the
signer of deals the shadow broker
of the multiverse universe podcast
please
tell the people find people what you got
going on where can they find you first i
got to say
maddie it's a pleasure just to be on a
podcast with you oh
you and carrick specifically were one of
my main inspirations
so thank you just to be on here it's
just a big deal for me
awesome happy to meet you oh thank you
and i just
so if you guys want to find us i just do
stuff in the background for the most
part
um i have a show on mondays
i call multiverse show you can find me
on twitter at multiverse show
uh my my twitter account got axe so we
got that one
what's the twitter we gotta plug
uh we do seven o'clock on mondays seven
o'clock eastern time it's a really bad
job of promoting yeah
i know i'm terrible i'm terrible
i i i i'm gonna need you to get a note
card like a note card to carry around
he will close the deal on you i'll tell
you that dude
we keep a short show 45 minutes to an
hour we didn't don't try to occupy too
much of your time
so just show up at seven o'clock we have
a good group of guys we do gaming
um comics talk about whatever geeky
stuff is going on
so we're doing our e3 show tomorrow so
that's gonna be fun
we like doing at least two weeks early
so uh
give our real predictions before we do
like oh though all the week before where
stuff gets leaked we try to avoid that
same
real stuff absolutely you brother man
you've been putting it down for a while
again
always you know one thing about us we're
never gonna forget
what you have done for us always been a
great supporter
good guy personal friend and um it was
always good i had to get you on too
because i was like
oh this is bethesda it was a perfect
thing man so i was so happy that you
could make it
and we got the camera so i was happy
yeah
we're going to find people find you what
you got going on sir you can find me on
twitter
twitter lord addict iop now you can find
me in king
this uh tomorrow i don't know yet what
time but
sometime tomorrow we'll be playing it
takes two oh
i'll just have to uh give you the exact
time i don't know yet
you can also find uh my mass effect
review right
from a first-time player uh i got all
them and uh
i i i you know you know i'm not gonna
give nothing don't give it away don't
give it away
click that link man that's gonna click
that link definitely go check that and
you know what
since we're going to close out go over
there man and show our dude fawn some
love so far
over there tell him the iron lord
he's got great work you got to try it
out man i think you'll enjoy his content
another good dude in the community man
you already know and of course
they're calling you the lord of spec ops
now
the specification gang resolution
lord king the prophet of xbox in the
building talking that talk definitely
entertaining with that time for sure you
know i got the
last laugh but salute to you bro what do
you got going on besides the amazing
king of the statue and you got the beat
to turn around i saw the beat turn
around
first and foremost uh let's give it up
to the most amazing smile on youtube
um oh man maddie plays
a little no secret right you get a
framed picture of me just like put it on
top
don't worry it's already there they
don't know oh my god
but um a little known secret like i i
went and i'm watching to find and do and
um
that's there's like maddie plays so i
checked my twitter and i was like oh
he's following me when i'm back
i hate that you know somebody following
you just don't know and i
was like oh no i said i hope you don't
think i was being rude
but uh i love the stuff that you guys do
over there thank you
and it's very super important that you
have a connection
with the people that you're with and
that you work in that space to to show
those talents like you said you know
nobody's gonna outwork you
um at all and you know the content shows
uh it shows heart it shows determination
and it shows that you're willing to
learn and grow
like from you know your past experiences
and stuff like that but
it also shows that when i'm listening to
you talk and i'm listening to key
moments i'm looking at you know how
you viewed video games going through
it's a natural progression
that you know you are the western rpg uh
you know foremost
knowledgeable guy when it comes to
certain things and and i couldn't wait
to have you on today
to talk about that stuff you know and i
do appreciate what you bring together
yeah
let me just uh say because you guys have
been so complimentary of my stuff i i
need to
say at the end of all this that you know
you you i hope you
all know how good of a rep your show has
like it's insane man like i hear
extremely good things where i typically
like check it out
i see like what's going on what's the
flow what's it like with the host but
like
there is such good word of mouth with
your show and it's growing just know
that because like we
like literally i was like i'm topping
out man i was like there's no doubter
i'll make whatever time i need like you
guys bring a good show like it was fun
it flew by like even in comparison i'll
say to my own shows man like your show
flies by like i can't believe i'm
sitting here for three and a half hours
like that's wow
bro like usually
it's always nice when people take a bet
on us like you know
we definitely it's not even a bad that's
what i'm trying to say it's like you
bring a good show
you bring energy and you're you're
knowledgeable
but we thank you for guys and either i
was i was saving the best for last
uh anchorman you know i love you to
death i love you
deaf and i do appreciate the fact that
you do have your camera on it means a
lot to me
because you know when i met you in
person we had such a great time
um and you are a dear friend of me like
i told you my conversations and stuff is
open to you at all times
always also i need to be back on the
multiverse because i was there
and holds me back and i feel kind of
like
oh but here we go you catch me on
fridays 9 00 p.m on dcx that's where we
talk
uh comic books video games entertainment
and
statues gotta like cox said i got it to
turn around kos
is up right now with phoenix this is
dark phoenix
the part one is up you can hear that
story but part two i think you're a
little bit more interested in because
people love the dark side
and i'm going to go into how she became
who
she is and why she's probably the most
feared entity
in the marvel universe uh so follow me
on twitter
uh king david otw uh
find me on xbox king david otw where i
actually
play with people and don't force you to
pay me to play with you know people say
oh you always tweeting i'm playing games
all day
leave me alone and i work all night um
and also you can find us on
um iron lords podcasts i mean
logicgaming.net yes sir
where if you want some of the
information from these statues i don't
go into size and dimensions and stuff
like that
i leave that to the law of cognito he
does he works very hard
on the synapsis and gives you the
dimensions and stuff of the statues
so if you want to know dimensions prices
and all that other stuff that's
there so please go check that stuff out
and also get a chance to
look at uh some great content that's up
there at this moment all right go to
gaming.net also you can see this amazing
collection this man has
and all these other statues as well with
the joint um real quick the superchats
gaming for take to our super chat
he was like stuck at work until six you
better wait for me cog yes i will we
will do that with fitness on vodka
i don't know man your six is like nine
to us so like
anyway hectic hectic we'll follow from
chat our second their ps5 is keeping us
from greatness good grieving
dangerous game dangerous 5 000 shout out
to sony in their 25 games with half
being ips new ip
and 15 of those games being vr sorry not
sorry stay messy king
david two pounds super chat thank you
all for the entertainment on the laws
they know thank you guys for rocking
with us again
tremendous please check us out again an
absolute pleasure
for normatic to be here thank you so
much for the compliments do
a joy and enjoy your sunday we got more
fun stuff coming up e3 is approaching
everybody let's see anybody got anything
else to say addict oh yeah we're
full okay not police station oh my god
oh definitely go to fawns don't forget
to hit up fawns man don't forget
so look that's all i got everybody enjoy
your sunday
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
uh